[Musique]
michel wieviorka bonsoir bonsoir nouveau
recevant pour une chaîne internet qui
s'appelle thinker view nous sommes en
direct est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succinctement donc michel
wieviorka je suis sociologue c'est comme
ça qu'on me définis du directeur
d'études dans une institution qui
s'appelle école des hautes études en
sciences sociales où on est en principe
toute sa vie directeur d'études j'ai
l'âge d'être traités j'ai 75 ans et
voilà pour commencer ce que je peux vous
dire comment et vous ayez choisi d'être
sociologue c'est quoi votre domaine de
de particulier qu'est ce qui vous a
marqué le plus dans votre sociaux dans
vos études on vous recherche donc alors
bon il fallait que je raconte tout ça
moi ça m'a passionné mais je suis pas
tant que ça poussera les gens qui nous
écoutent enfin en gros mois c'est le
s'est pas complètement le hasard c'est à
dire que moi j'ai d'abord fait une école
de commerce vous avez en face de sony
parfait vous avez en face de vous
quelqu'un qui a reçu son diplôme de
l'école supérieure de commerce de paris
en 1968 année où tout le monde a reçu
son diplôme avec une spécialisation
finance comptabilité je n'ai pas besoin
de vous dire qu'il ne m'en reste pas pas
grand chose et harry 68 je me suis dit
faut que je fasse quand même autre chose
que du commerce du marketing et des
choses comme ça donc je passe les
détails et un beau jour je décide de
faire un doctorat après avoir fait un
doctorat d'économie de faire un doctorat
de sociologie et un doctorat d'état
c'est à dire le truc supérieure avec
alain touraine ou plus exactement avec
un autre sociologue manuel castells que
vous connaissez peut-être parce que
c'est le pape chez les sociologues de
tout ce qui est réseaux numériques
internet a fait une grande figure
mondiale au mondial un type très très
intéressant qui le dit moi j'ai pas le
droit de diriger des doctorat d'état on
va demander à touraine bref je me suis
retrouvé dans la sociologie d'alain
touraine qui était un homme de gauche
mais pas marxiste donc moi qui étais
plutôt gauchiste à compliquer un peu les
relations mais c'était très bien et donc
il m'a appris à faire la sociologie et
c'est quelque chose pour moi de très
important
10les phénomène de terrorisme à cause de
votre beau frère ah ça c'est autre chose
alors donc avec touraine j'étudie alors
les mouvements sociaux de l'époque le
mouvement étudiant le mouvement voyez la
bonté choses assez classique si on peut
dire et puis un beau jour mon beau frère
qui était à linge et sema me dit michel
j'ai quelque chose pour toi il faut
savoir qui est alain g smart parce que
ceux qui nous écoutent ont peut-être des
souvenirs un peu ou ne connaissent pas
j'essaie mars était un des trois leader
de mai 68 et avec cohn bendit
l'incarnation des étudiants il y avait
sauvageau c'était le l'apparatchik
étudiants pour simplifier le patron du
syndicat voilà du syndicat étudiant et
j'ai ce marché le patron des profs
c'était le secrétaire général du
syndicat des profs et la choisit de
joutes de rejoindre le mouvement donc il
est il embarque les profs ou non le
mouvement de 68 mai 68 ça dure pas
éternellement et une fois que ça retombe
lui veut il fait partie de ceux qui
veulent continuer mais quand un
mouvement retombées que vous voulez
continuer et bien votre discours devient
artificiel vous vous radicaliser et donc
il devient maui swiss certains encore
plus dans le barreau isme y crée avec
d'autres la cause du peuple à gauche
prolétarienne enfin toutes sortes de
choses très très très gauchiste et y
flirte avec le terrorisme je leur ai
tellement avec le terrorisme que il se
fait arrêter par la police il était jugé
je crois que c'était la cour de sûreté
de l'état encore à l'époque il fait un
bond une bonne année de prison il sort
de là et au bout de quelques années il
je veux dire il remonte la pente il sort
de tout ce que ça veut dire des
terroristes ou quasi terroriste et il se
rapproche du parti socialiste et ensuite
il fait d'autres choses et en 81 81 il
publie un bouquin qui s'appelle
l'engrenage terroriste moi je veux plus
j'avais jamais vu le moindre intérêt
pour le terrorisme l'engrenage
terrorisme où il explique comment est ce
que c'est que le come on devient
terroristes et comment c'est difficile
d'en sortir
et il est invité à l'époque la grande
émission de télé c'était apostrophe part
il invita avec bernard pivot cette
émission super je crois que tu es le
vendredi soir vous pouvez pas manquer
cette émission donc il est invité chez
bernard pivot il explique en affaires et
il reçoit un coup de fil le lendemain
d'un type qui lui dit voilà je suis avec
une dizaine d'autres
gens comme moi on est des italiens en
cavale en france mitterrand nous laisse
eux
nous laisse exister en france des
mesures ont fait rien et on se demandait
ce qu'on continue ou pas la lutte armée
et vous nous avez vraiment donné envie
de réfléchir est-ce que vous accepteriez
de passer du temps pour réfléchir avec
nous et j'espère leur dis ça c'est pas
mon boulot mais je vous mettre en
contact avec mon beau-frère et un
téléphone et me dit coûte
qu'est ce que tu dirais d'étudier le
terrorisme avec ta méthode on s'est
aimés tonnes/an travailler avec des
groupes ba je vous dis amen mois des
terroristes et je travaillerai avec eux
je crois qu'il blaguait jamais dit
justement donc je me retrouve comme ça
en relation avec une bande de deux
dizaines de types c'était des durs de
dieu encore plus dur que les gens de là
des brigades rouges je rentre pas dans
toute l'histoire de ce phénomène et donc
ils acceptent ils acceptent ce que je
leur propose a dit voilà on va se réunir
et on recevra des invités en privez pas
de spectateurs pape témoin et tout ce
qui se dirait vraiment entre nous on va
recevoir ces gens là pour discuter avec
vous je on va les choisir ensemble il
faut que ce soit des partenaires ou des
adversaires de la lutte armée comme ça
ça vous aidera à mieux réfléchir et
après je vous proposerai mon analyse de
de tout ce qu'on a vécu ensemble alors
ils me disent on lutte contre le patron
je cherchais un patron d'alfa romeo en
italie on eu ton luth au nom de la
classe ouvrière je vais chercher des
syndicalistes à turin de la fiat à
l'époque la fiat les syndicats de la
fiat c'était la crème de la crème et
cetera je me souviens plus du détail
mais je fais un assez grand nombre
d'entretiens avec eux et à l'issue de
tout ça je leur présente mon analyse de
ce que
de ce qui était en jeu dans tout ça
c'est une période vraiment intéressante
d'autant qu'après ça je me dis bon mais
ça c'est un aspect du phénomène italien
il y en a d'autres et à l'époque c'était
très facile de trouver d'autres italiens
paris à l'époque vous alliez au siège de
libération au journal libération vous
poussez la porte et vous disais vous
voulez rencontrer les italiens les
camarades italiens n'y avait aucune
difficulté bon et en particulier il y en
avait à peu près 1000 à paris
qui s'était réfugié à paris il avait
ouvert des bistrots où il finissait dans
certains endroits van bon il avait des
avocats j'ai pu en rencontrer un certain
nombre donc j'ai fait un deuxième groupe
avait quand même démarche je continue
vous m'arrêtez cl c'est très intéressant
et et à l'issue tout ça alain touraine
qui m'avait beaucoup aidé j'avais été
aussi beaucoup aidé par françois furet
l'historien qui était à l'époque le
président de l'école des hautes études
en sciences sociales qui m'avait donné
sur ça il avait une sorte de cagnotte à
8 il m'avait donné de quoi aller payer
les billets d'avion pour faire venir des
gens d'italie à paris des choses comme
ça les met vraiment beaucoup peiné et et
tour elle m'avait dit wieviorka fait un
séminaire là dessus donc je veux ouvrait
un séminaire il se développe
la présentation de tout ça que bout de
quelques mois est un de mes étudiants
que tu ailles aussi âgé que moi qui
viens voir et qui me dira c'est
passionnant ce que vous faites mais il
n'ya pas que le terrorisme d'extrême
gauche il yad'autres terrorisme en
particulier nationaliste jeter oui bien
sûr il ya par exemple le terrorisme
basque habache de 10 amenez moi disent
ah mais moi dix membres de thé à et je
fais la même chose avec eux bike
justement et m'explique que son ancienne
petite amie et qui s'étaient séparés
mais avec il était resté en bons termes
vivez avec un des grands un des grands
patrons de terre et crack je me suis
retrouvé à continuer ce genre de
recherche au pays basque espagnol avec
des gens qui avaient quitté otéra qui
était pas loin de thé et c'est donc
voilà et pour continuer et puis après
j'arrête mais c'est vous me demandez ce
qui ce qui m'intéresse
après tout ça je me dis bon mais la
grande affaire aujourd'hui c'est le
terrorisme international j'ai la
question palestinienne
à l'époque si on parlait un peu aussi
d'un terrorisme arménien lasala armée
secrète pour la libération de l'arménie
qui en fait du ter à mesure de
prolongement arménien de du terrorisme
pro-palestiniens dont je vous dis faut
que je continue là dessus donc porter
fallait aller au liban et alors là j'ai
pas pu faire du travail de groupe mais
j'ai pu faire mes enquêtes complété
alors comprenez et puis je suis allé
aussi en amérique latine parce que
c'était l'époque du sentier lumineux je
peux rencontrer le sentier lumineux
parce que ça c'était à mon avis
impossible c'est déjà très très à part
si je peux dire alors que les autres et
palestiniens les basques et où il avait
plein de copains l'ajout coûte un peu
première question se planter comme ça à
organiser des entretiens un peu secret
avec été terroriste est-ce que vous avez
été approché par les services de
renseignements amélie fait beaucoup plus
j'ai fait beaucoup plus alors
et je vous parle d'un grand d'une grande
excitation
alors je commence avec les italiens et
justement gesma qui je parle de tout ça
me dit faut que tu préviennent les flics
à l'époque la gauche venait d'arriver
aux affaires et donc je suis rempliront
mitterrand et donc je suis allé
je suis allé voir quelqu'un qui
s'appelle il est mort donc je peux en
parler louis joinet qui était le
conseiller pour les problèmes de
terrorisme du premier ministre
je suis allé le voir quand on j'allais
le voir après j'ai revue s'ouvre on a
une relation très amicale devant son
bureau y ait des gens qui faisaient la
queue alors ça parlait basse que c'est
par les irlandais ça parlait arménien et
enfin sur tout ce que la france pouvait
compter non pas terrorisme et de
personnes concernées par la lutte armée
il était en contact avec donc je lui ai
parlé de ça et il m'a donné le conseil
de près du corps elle m'a dit comment
prévenir la police et c'est ce qui fait
que mes réunions je les faisais dans les
locaux de la de l'école des hautes
études en sciences sociales dans le rôle
parfois même au rez de chaussée les
flics étaient au courant et les gays et
les membres de mon but était au courant
que les flics étaient au courant donc
j'étais c'était rigolo c'est à dire je
n'ai jamais donné la moindre information
aux policiers n'ont d'ailleurs jamais
demandé et
mais comme ça tout était en règle et ça
s'est passé très très bien alors
ensuite oui ma grande vexations c'est
quand j'ai fait les recherches sur le
pays basque parce que là j'ai rencontré
quand même des drôles de lashkar bon
mais tout ça sans jamais savoir ce
qu'ils avaient fait mais en me doutant
qu'ils avaient fait des choses ou qu'ils
allaient faire des choses mais là
vraiment et à ma grande vexations sais
qu'un jour je crois que c'est l'express
ou le point publie la liste des milliers
de personnes qui sont sur écoute alors
tout ce qui bouge était sur écoute je
n'étais pas sur écoute et je me suis pas
suite alors c'est pas la peine d'avoir
les contacts que j'ai de faire ce que je
fais pour ne pas avoir droit aux
honneurs de deux des écoutes de l'elysée
vous parliez de terrorisme italien
d'ultragauche est ce que ça vous parle
un truc qui s'appelle les résout glad
you ça me dit vaguement quelque chose
mais est ce que c'était pas plutôt des
trucs d'extrême droite selon vous parler
de mes souvenirs je crois que c'était de
gauche c'est possible écoutez c'était
yade s'était plaint de droite voilà
parce que l'italie l'italie c'est un
pays ça a été un laboratoire du
terrorisme parce qu'il ya eu en même
temps du terrorisme d'extrême gauche et
du terrorisme d'extrême droite et c'est
pour ça que gladio c'était peut-être
même des trucs de réseau c'était
peut-être mes souvenirs sont vagues dont
je peux j'espère ne pas dire des bêtises
mais c'était peut-être un des trucs liés
à des services un peu un peu glauque
disons
que des services d'état non je ne sais
pas on l'on peut imaginer revenons à nos
moutons
on va continuer à s'être entretien on
est très contents de vous avoir parce
que comme la société va mal il faut
revoir les historiens et les sociologues
en priorité donc on en profite
en ce moment la france c'est compliqué
on vend 20 ont pas encore parlé du
terrorisme encore mais mais pour
prévenir une téléspectateurs et nous
internautes on va élargir un petit peu
le prisme de lecture revenant sur le
terrorisme
c'est difficile d'en sortir pourquoi
alors c'est difficile d'en sortir parce
que
quand vous êtes dans une organisation de
lutte armée il est exceptionnel que des
gens vous disent je suis terroristes
nous dit je pratique la lutte armée je
suis résistantes ou je suis résistants
ou combattants de la liberté où
notamment lorsque vous êtes dans une
organisation comme celle là d'abord
c'est difficile d'en sortir parce que
plus elle est active plus vous êtes dans
la clandestinité
plus vous dépendez les uns des autres -
vous voyez d'autres personnes que ce que
celle que sont liés à votre à votre
réseau ou à votre groupe et donc vous
êtes un peu dans un monde très fermé sur
difficile de sortir d'un monde fermé
premièrement et puis deuxièmement c'est
comme tous les phénomènes totalitaire en
sortir c'est rompre avec ce qui a été le
sens qui a envahi toute votre existence
quand vous êtes un vrai terroriste il ya
que ça rien n'existe d'autre les cycles
même s'il peut y avoir des histoires
d'amour des histoires d'argent que c'est
il ya que ça qui donne un sens à votre
existe donc en sortir
ça veut dire accepter que le sens que
vous avez mis jusqu'ici c'est pas le bon
c'est très dur je vous donne un exemple
qui n'est rien avec le terrorisme mais
qui concerne ma soeur j'ai une soeur
annette qui a été ma liste mais pro
chinoise et donc qu'elle était c'est une
façon mer sans avoir été en chine ces
cinq six mais justement fut merveilleuse
c'est pour ça que et donc elle était
convaincue que tout ça a été formidable
et elle était vivre en chine elle a
travaillé en chine et pour vivre cette
expérience qu est l expérience
totalitaire et puis elle est revenue en
france vous deux ans et bien je peux
vous dire c'était très dur pour elle de
de sortir de tout ça elle en a tiré ses
productions pas elle en a tiré un livre
y'a pas longtemps où elle explique c'est
un des rares livres que j'ai jamais lu
où on explique à quel point c'est dur
intellectuellement politiquement
moralement de sortir de ces phénomènes
c'est comme si je vous demandais ce que
c'est dur de sortir d'une secte ou
est-ce que c'est dur de sortir d'une
idéologie ultra politique exactement se
passer ça mais c'est des trucs qui vous
prennent et qui parfois vous prennent en
plus concrètement savez quand vous avez
reçues et gamme aura un jour où l'on
brasse nous on adore on adore et bien
moi et il a
il a été communiste pierre bonjour ils
l'ont viré
il environ on se fait virer et quand on
se fait virer alors dans son cas ça
allait mais quand on se fait virer c'est
très violent on perd ses amis on perd
parfois son job on perd son gagne pain
ou perte ou d'un seul coup donc c'est
difficile pratiquement et
intellectuellement les deux à la fois
quel regard vous portez sur les partis
politiques ou les mouvements politiques
d'extrême que ce soit d'extrême d'ultra
droite ou d'ultra gauche
moi je je suis ce que à l'époque du
gauchisme triomphant dans les années 70
on appelait un démocrate alors je vous
dire ce que c'était que l'un démocrate
un démocrate c'est quelqu'un dit tu nous
prêtons appartement n'a besoin de ça
pour faire des réunions dans ta cave on
va mettre des trucs tu vas pas voir ce
que c'est ta bagnole évidemment il faut
qu'on puisse s'en servir tout une
douzaine de temps en temps de l'argent
tout ça comme ça amicalement et puis le
jour où la révolution a eu lieu et où on
a reporté la révolution te coupe la
gorge sans sans état d'âme c'est est-ce
un démocrate donc moi j'ai toujours été
un démocrate il ya quelqu'un qui écoute
qui essaie de comprendre qui peut avoir
une certaine compréhension de tout ça
mais qui n'en est pas voilà je n'en suis
pas alors c'est ça le regard que je
porte ces phénomènes est donc ce qui
m'intéresse dans ces phénomènes scellé
c'est la façon dont ça se construit luz
dont sa s'enferment dans la radicalité
c'est à dire le contraire de la
démocratie
l'incapacité à dialoguer à
échanger c'est la culture de la
radicalité c'est le contraire de la
culture du débat si le contraire du 2
culture de du compromis de la
négociation donc voilà donc mais je
comprends je comprends que ça existe
donc j'ai un regard de compréhension
mais très très vite ça me révulse parce
que très vite ça débouche sur la
violence la violence vis-à-vis des
autres et la violence vis-à-vis des
membres même de ce cet univers parce que
si on marche pas droit on n'y a plus sa
place
si je comprends bien c'est si on
n'applique pas la même pureté
idéologique que le groupe on se fait
exclure on n'y a pas sa place bien sûr
bien sûr et y compris quand le mouvement
derrière c'est à dire que ces mouvements
là ont des histoires en général ça
commence et au début c'est merveilleux
au début c'est merveilleux ils sont
portés par une idée ils ont des gens qui
comprennent suis pas le seul à
comprendre ils ont par exemple les
terroristes italiens dont je vous
parlais tout à l'heure au début dans les
usines il ya des ouvriers qui disent bah
oui c'est ce qu'il faut faire faux parce
que c'est pas une violence extrême
encore et puis c'est une violence qui
keith hawton omise
cli qui prend ce qui existe c'est
logique qu'ils enferment sur elle même
et là ça dérape complètement et ça peut
aller jusqu'à la violence pour la
violence est là la catastrophe la
catastrophe avec votre expérience avec
votre lecture comment vous jugez la
france et qu'elle quelles perspectives
d'évolution vous voyez est ce que vous
voyez des mouvements radicaux se
radicaliser comme les italiens est ce
que à gauche comme à droite est-ce que
ça sent la poudre
c'est difficile de répondre ce que je
risque d'être démenti dans l'heure qui
suit donc il faut être prudent donc ce
que je vois moi aujourd'hui en france
c'est en termes politiques on va parler
politique ce que je vois en france c'est
un centre centre droite le président
actuel les gens qui se reconnaissent
dans son action ça c'est le centre
droite et puis ensuite le désert
la pub parti socialiste comme chacun
peut le constater le parti communiste
s'est plus grand chose et le désert
jusqu'à une certaine radicalité mais qui
n'est pas de l'extrémisme et qui n'est
pas de la violence je dirais jamais je
ne suis pas mélenchonistes ou avec la
princesse soumises je dirais jamais de
la france insoumise que cd de la graine
de terroristes ou de la graine de
violence c'est pas vrai d'un côté après
on pourra parler socialement laspales
politique d'un autre côté c'est la même
chose et puis de droite l est
républicain
soit yi et rejoignent macro soit ils
font les yeux doux alessandra est donc
le désert pareil j'exagère bien sûr et
puis on arrive à l'extrême droite et là
il n'ya pas une mais y en a deux et vous
remarquerez une chose c'est que tant que
l'extrême droite française et dans la
respectabilité veut gagner des élections
non seulement elle n'est pas violente
mais elle est embêté quand y ait de la
violence qui seraient commises en son
nom et ça c'est une chose très
importante
autrement dit jamais je n'accuserai
marine le pen de de préparer des actions
violentes par contre je pourrais dire
que l'existence même de l'idéologie
qu'elle qu'elle incarne peut donner des
idées de violence à certains mais c'est
pas c'est pas imputables à cette extrême
droite là et donc c'est quand l'extrême
droite n'est pas politiquement forte et
ne peut pas espérer des victoires
électorales qu'elle peut devenir
beaucoup plus violente je pense donc
début de réponse on est dans une période
où il ya ce vide de la gauche et de la
droite classique et il ya des
radicalités qui sont très différentes
parce que la radicalité de gauche
n'exclut pas enlever en ce moment
n'exclut pas du de l' échange avec des
gens non radicaux à gauche puisque la
prochaine élection les prochaines
élections législatives
ils vont marcher ensemble alors que la
droite essaie vraiment de l'extrémisme
et ça exclut des alliances avec la
droite classique et entre la droite
classique et le rassemblement national
donc faut pas c'est pas une symétrie ben
c'est pas parfaitement symétrique donc
voilà comment je vois la scène politique
mais à part que la politique et la
société et tous ne passent pas par la
politique et je dirais même - la
politique est capable de traiter
politiquement des attentes les demandes
les les rues d'angers propulsion et de
transformer ça en propositions en débat
tient moins les politiques sont capables
de faire ça m'a plu en dessous ça
bouillonne autrement et on profite pour
tout une question internet
que j'ai vu du coin de l'oeil quelles
sont les conditions requises pour qu'un
mouvement terroriste et klose
spontanément existe-t-il en particulier
un ou plusieurs points de bascule que
pense-t-il des travaux de naomi klein
sur la stratégie du choc alors je
connais naomi clamé pas là dessus je
connais son jeu son travail formidable
jane vingtaine d'années pour dénoncer
nos logos et les grandes marques bon
mais ça je connais pas cette chose là
donc je préfère ne pas répondre mais il
faut bien comprendre une chose c'est que
lui on se trompe quand on croit que le
terroriste c'est quelqu'un qui a reçu un
jour pour une raison pour une autre une
sorte illuminations et qui basculent
d'entre autre chose ça arrive peut-être
mais en réalité - les organisations que
j'ai que j'ai pu connaître ou sur
lesquels j'ai pu lire des choses c'est
des processus historiques et politiques
qui prennent du temps
ci j'évoquais tout à l'heure à terre ou
pays basque si vous voulez comprendre
eta
ça commence par la déception de la
jeunesse basque qui croyaient que les
américains aller [__] en l'air franco
est délivré l'espagne
de la dictature et qui s'aperçoivent que
pour des raisons géopolitiques les
américains s'approche de franco parce
qu'il sent dans la guerre froide et que
prof le problème pour eux c'est l'union
soviétique et que du coup franco
continue à opprimer beaucoup de monde
dont les basques et à ce moment là la
jeunesse basque dit mais notre parti
nationaliste qui est réformiste et
prudent qu on aurait dû presque un parti
démocrate chrétien si vous voulez et ben
oui on n'obtiendra rien du tout avec lui
mais tout ça prend du temps c'est des
discussions c'est des lectures c'est des
gens qui se regroupent c'est au début
pas du tout la pratique de la violence
souvent aussi en théorie l'idée que non
on n'utilisera jamais une violence
extrême en ont la contrôlera etc et puis
il se met en place des logiques qui
conduisent à plus de violence donc et on
se trompe complètement donc si on croit
comprendre la violence comme ça par une
sorte de d'illumination chez les gens
moi j'ai connu des gens qui m'ont
expliqué que par exemple il n'avait pas
du tout l'intention d'utiliser la
violence mais un jour où il s'agit se
procurer de l'argent pour l'organisation
on décide de faire une banque puis ça
tourne mal donc quand ça tourne mal on
tue un vigile ou je ne sais plus quoi et
va lui prendre son arme bon et donc on
se retrouve avec des armes et ouais
c'est des trucs comme ça bon qu'ils sont
on ne les comprend qu'après coup quand
les gens voulaient ils ont raconté voilà
on peut pas les concevoir avant il n'y a
pas d'explications simples et c'est
certainement pas la même pour une
personne ou pour une autre pour un
groupe pour un autre qu'une fois qu'il
ya un groupe alors il a sa logique y met
en place son organisation il met en
place ses structures
les brigades rouges étaient marrants et
olga de rouge par exemple à une époque
je sais pas si on peut dire attendez non
bien sûr qu'on va y avait eu une époque
où l'été c'était sacré fallait prendre
des vacances donc pas au mois d'août
vous n'aviez pas d'attentats parce que
vacances j'exagère un petit peu mais pas
beaucoup donc si vous voulez y perdez
des côtés même bureaucratique et ce qui
s'est passé hier en italie c'est que ce
côté bureaucratique a été débordé en
quelque sorte par des milliers et des
milliers de jeunes qui voulaient prendre
les armes qu'ils voulaient vraiment
faire la révolution et qui trouvaient
que justement où les brigades rouges
avaient pas assez fort assez vite qui
sont rentrés dans les brigades rouges où
l'on crée deux organisations et qui ont
été vers de plus en plus de radicalité
en même temps que le monde ouvrier
comprenez de moins en moins et
s'éloignait vous avez j'ai plus fait le
terrorisme politique pas le terrorisme
religieux
alors c'est la grande affaire non moi je
suis vieux jeu donc moi j'ai étudié des
terrorismes non religieux est la grande
affaire c'est ce qui s'est passé pas
seulement avec l'islam mais surtout pour
nous avec l'islam c'est-à-dire ce moment
où mais ça commence avant le terrorisme
ça commence par la révolution
l'idée de révolution qu'en france c'est
1789 puis la grande révolution
soviétique c'est ce genre de choses puis
un beau jour arrive from any révolution
religieuse et est donc tout autre image
de la révolution il a fallu un peu la
reconstruire à partir de ça et on est en
algérie les gia qui vont être terroriste
et religieux et on va découvrir donc
l'islam religieux l'islamisme et le
terrorisme
qui s'en réclament et donc ça moi je ne
vais pas étudié je le comprend peut-être
mieux que d'autres parce que
j'ai acquis quand même une certaine
expérience de ces choses mais moi je
suis j'ai arrêté d'étudier le terrorisme
au moment où ce nouveau terrorisme se
mettait en place il est différent il est
global alors qu'avant ils étaient soit
dans un cadre limité soit international
mais ils étaient pas que globale il est
global il est très moderne à bien des
égards ce terrorisme et surtout et
surtout contrairement à l'ancien les je
connais il est sans limites et c'est ça
qui a décontenancé au début les experts
ce qui fait la lutte antiterroriste
parce que vous comprenez quand les
terroristes italiens haute il voulait
pas donner la mort alors pas du tout
du tout donc le jour des gens disent moi
je vais tuer et en tuant je sais que je
vais peut-être mourir et je veux même
peut-être nourrir et c'est peut-être
pour ça que je suis en train d'utiliser
les uns le martyre isme si vous voulez
changer énormément de choses donc on va
dans autre chose avec le terrorisme
religieux ça je n'ai pas étudié je peux
en parler mais ce serait plus ce serait
moi si moins sérieux un peu un peu plus
superficielle
quand vous étiez avec les
entre guillemets terroriste selon le
point de vue
d'où l'on se place
est ce que vous avez
comment formuler sa est ce que vous
n'avez pas eu envie de glisser ou vous
avez gardé votre recul est ce qu est ce
que ça pouvait dévier alors
vous endoctrinés l'espace du tsunami non
mais c'est le contraire moi j'étais là
tous les gens que j'ai rencontrés
alors tous les gens que j'ai pu
rencontrer même ceux qui n'ont pas bougé
mais ils savaient très bien qui c'était
j'étais un sociologue qui veut
comprendre qui veut analyser et qui veut
leur demander de participer à l'analyse
de leurs propres actions mais rien que
le fait d'accepter ça c'est le fait
d'introduire un peu de distance et par
conséquent c'était ouvrir des brèches et
donc moi je sais j'ai pas eu je vais pas
vous dire j'ai fait bouger des gens je
ne le sais pas mais je sais que j'ai
réussi à faire en sorte que des
terroristes soient capables d'analyser
leurs propres actions alors si vous
pouvez analyser votre propre action vous
prenez de la distance par rapport à la
lutte armée par rapport à la violence
nécessairement et donc moi je n'ai pas
pu travailler vraiment je n'ai croisé
d'autres plus rapidement mais c'est
qu'ils gerland mené des recherches de
groupe c'était des gens qui a été à
moitié est partie ou complètement partie
sortie qui était sur ma trajectoire un
peu à l'ag smart si vous voulez qui est
en train de sortir de tout ça quand je
vous entends vous dites un canton scène
à lille on prend du recul c'est sa
c6 démarche de sociologues ou c'est une
démarche de psychiatres à travers moi je
suis pas un psychiatre et se prêtant pas
guérir les gens j'ai voulu le genre de
sociologie que j'aime faire la plupart
de mes collègues font tout à fait autre
chose moi j'aime bien faire une
sociologie dans laquelle je travaille
avec des acteurs et je les aide à élever
leur niveau d'analysé
avec l'anthropologue bien il a des
entreprises qui pourraient faire des
choses un peu comme moi mais pas
influencer son sujet de faire ça non
alors on me l'a reproché enfin au
courant auquel j'appartiens on me l'a
reproché mais il s'agit pas d'influencé
mais si je vous dis réunissant nous
réfléchissons on en place d'un processus
vous êtes libres d'accepter ou pas je
peux vous payez je vais pas vous obliger
bon ça vous intéresse ça vous intéresse
vous allez réfléchir et à la sortie tout
ça vous aurez peut-être une vision un
peu autres de ce qui a été votre action
c'est ça l'idée donc c'est introduire
c'est pas comment vous dirai comment
vous dire c'est pas manipuler c'est pas
influencer si au contraire dur dire je
vous prends au sérieux je te prends au
sérieux je te propose d'élever la
capacité d' analyses tu feras ce que tu
voudras dessous couture a mieux compris
mais je racontais que sur ce qui m'a
vraiment fait très plaisir je fais donc
mon travail de groupe avec un groupe de
deux d'anciens de terre que jean qui
était sorti de ça mais est certain de ce
groove avait eu des responsabilités
importantes dans cette organisation
donc on réfléchit et à la fin de tout ça
c'est très tendu cdd d c'est très
difficile je je leur explique un certain
nombre de choses que j'ai compris de ce
que m'avait dit il rallie accepte où ils
refusent mon analyse enfin peu importe
ça dure ça dure ça dure et en
particulier tout un samedi bien samedi
entier comme ça de débats alors qu'on
avait rencontré des deux places donc on
est fatigués et on décide de se
retrouver le lendemain matin dimanche
donc si l'on voulait il voulait
réfléchir c'est vrai et le lendemain
matin un de ceux qui avaient participé à
ce groupe arrive avec un gros un gros
volume un gros machin genre albums
photos et il dit voilà je suis rentré à
la maison je ne pouvais pas dormir après
tout les discussions qu'on a eues et
j'ai ressorti cet album dans lequel j'ai
gardé des tracts des photos des
documents de l'organisation etc et j'ai
relu l'histoire de certains événements
qui me sont venues à la lumière des
discussions que nous avons eues hier à
pour moi c'était merveilleux donc voilà
quelqu'un qui me dit je fais quelque
chose intellectuellement de l'analyse
qu'on a construit ensemble passer des
moments afin arrive pas toujours c'est
le bon moment pour un chercheur parce
qu'ils se disent ah tiens voilà j'ai
contribué à élever le niveau d' analyse
de cette personne et donc du groupe du
coup puisque du coup tous y sont allés
de leur petit is abbaoui ça me rappelle
t elle je crois qu'on va telle attente
at elle cru tel machin je comprends
mieux maintenant ce qu'on a voulu faire
et pourquoi ces appâts marche etc
voilà c'est ça ma la sociologie qui
m'intéresse donc je suis pas là bas pour
endoctriner des gens ils feront ce
qu'ils voudront leur renommée des
analyses que je leur réponds et idées
radicaliser non non et d'abord il en si
c'est un chemin qui les mène vers reste
humble ablement vers ça mais c'est un
chemin long et alors il ya autre chose
c'est que c'est pas parce que ces gens
là ont eu un moment où ils ont été dans
l'analyse dans la compréhension et
cetera que ça va être durable moi il
m'est arrivé d'avoir le sentiment que
c'est yes été gagné par
intellectuellement et puis le lendemain
je découvre que il faudrait tout
recommencer si je voulais vraiment
stabilisé un peu tout ça autrement dit
c'est aussi des moments de rêve des
moments un peu particulier où on
réfléchit autrement et puis et puis
après la vie continue on est repris par
l'organisation par la vie quotidienne
par toutes sortes de choses bon mais
quand même je pense que le genre de
choses que j'ai fait a pu parce que je
le sais pas comment je le sais c'est que
1 en deux ans 5 ans 10 ans après il peut
m'arriver d'en croiser un par hasard ou
[Musique]
web ont fait des bonds ou quelqu'un qui
me reconnaît ou jeu en espagne quelqu'un
voit dans un média va
percevoir que ça a laissé des traces
amical mais c'était pas une amitié haute
que celle qui était liée à ce qu'ils
nous avaient rassemblé donc voilà donc
je sais que ça a eu un effet positif
quand même pour beaucoup de gens ces
expériences vous avez un regard sur la
politique de thé radicalisation oui
alors là non seulement j'ai un regret
mais je suis entre je suis entouré où
j'étais entouré de gens qui étaient les
meilleurs analystes de ses efforts c'est
très difficile peut-être même que le
mode et radicalisée si on n'est pas
n'est pas adaptée et que
c'est des trucs très long il faut
beaucoup de temps beaucoup de patience
beaucoup de soucis pour ceux qui font
ces politiques de de comprendre ce qui
s'est passé
d'accompagner donc dans la réflexion
ceux qui sont passés là
vous faites ce genre d'effort on vous
traite de l'islam aux gauchistes ou de
deux vendus ou et c'est alors que si
vous voulez que les gens ne sortent de
ces logiques il faut les accompagner et
en plus il faut les accompagner dans
seulement il doit logiquement c'est le
plus important mais il faut aussi les
accompagner concrètement parce que c'est
pas la peine de dire je vais l'aider
caldera tic elle disait pendant qu'ils
sont en prison si une fois qu'ils
sortent de prison ils n'ont pas un sou
ils ont pas de nouveaux copains etc et
voilà donc c'est très très compliqué en
prison du prisons surpeuplées où c'est
l'un qui se radicalise encore plus alors
ça c'est aussi ce qui ont ce qu'on a
observé évidemment c'est que les prisons
ont fabriqué la radicalité au delà de
leurs péchés ou de la réduire dans
certains cas on a compris ça mais voilà
c'est des choses cdc des processus très
délicat très compliqué et des gens qui
font ça bien des gens qui ont bien
compris et
ce qui complique tout c'est que c'est
pas on peut pas dire on va leur faire
faire machine arrière au point de départ
tepa radical et puis pour différentes
raisons tut radicaliser plus tard et un
moment et tu vas en syrie pour tuer et
puis tu reviens tu veux bien que c'était
de réfléchir l'idée qu' ils vont revenir
au point de départ c'est pas juste c'est
pas comme ça que ça va se passer il faut
réfléchir c'est les processus aux gens
vont se transformer eux-mêmes mais pas
en retrouvant ce qu'ils étaient avant
hawks et j'ai un exemple qui est patient
un problème de radicalisation mais vous
allez comprendre c'est une étudiante qui
avait fait une thèse formidable sur des
femmes qui avaient été c'était dans l'ex
yougoslavie
le village avait brûlé leur était arrivé
les pires horreurs donc on les avait mis
dans des camps de réfugiés ou continue
laurent 1 voilà après c'est sur un autre
registre et elle avait suivi ces femmes
et ces femmes une fois que les épisodes
étaient terminées une partie étaient
retournés dans leurs villages et notre
parti avait dit botton moi je veux c'est
fini je passe je vais la ville est bien
celle qui s'en était sorti chez celles
qui étaient allés à la ville celle qui
était retourné au villa louée pour
retrouver la vie d'avant c'était pas
possible
oui tout ça c'est jamais simple c'est
jamais rapide et on n'est jamais certain
que ce soit durable ça fait quand même
beaucoup de beaucoup de choses
on n'est pas dans la mouise la ba oui
mais on n'a pas le choix il faut
continuer
on arrive sur une période difficile pour
le monde occidental
pénurie de matières premières pénurie
énergétique précarité énergétique
inflation
des politiques qui ne trouvent pas de
solution qui ne font pas émerger des
propositions concrètes
pour vous ma question allait pas tout et
c'est le terrain propice à toutes les
radicalisations
7 le terrain propice à la crise et à des
conduites de crise mais pas forcément de
radicalisation c'est aussi le terrain
propice d'abord est-ce que les gens se
replient sur eux-mêmes sont radicalisés
regardez tous ces gens qui vous disent
mais moi je trouve ça très intéressant
démondialisation apprenons à vivre
localement ex que nous produisons le cas
demandez c'est pas des gens qui se
radicalise c'est des gens qui on invente
autre chose c'est même le terrain
propice justement à l'innovation
regardez ce qui se passe en ce moment on
je prends juste l'accord de la france
mais tous ces gens qui quittent la ville
pour essayer d'inventer un autre mode de
vie alors travailler à distance
peut-être mais aussi vivre autrement qui
déserte ou si les grandes écoles alors
y'en a qui déserte et on a eu un cas
récemment très intéressant à de gens qui
ont dit nous on veut pas
travailler pour l'agriculture
productiviste mais je trouve ça
merveilleux autrement dit on est dans
une période et ça pour moi c'est très
intéressant où il faut se dire voilà
tout change en ce moment ce que vous
avez dit est très juste on pourrait
vraiment continue à noircir le paysage
est bien dans une telle situation est-ce
que ça va nous entraîner vers le déclin
vers la catastrophe pas forcément la
violence ça peut être autre chose dans
le pays peu un pays comme une oie il
peut s'affaisser simplement ou est-ce
que c'est pas l'occasion d'une
transformation d'entrer dans un autre
univers et de dans une autre époque et
d'inventer des choses nouvelles
j'ai lu pendant le confinement un
bouquin formidable
alors me souviens alors l'auteur
s'appelle blum je crois ce script b l om
et
je me suis un peu du titre c'est un
historien allemands ou hollandais je ne
sais plus je pourrai vous le retrouve si
ça vous intéresse et c'est un livre où
il raconte la chose suivante il dit
voilà la fin du xvième siècle il ya eu
vraisemblablement un volcan cap était
quelque part qui a envoyé dans
l'atmosphère des telles quantités de
sang de poussière que toute la planète a
été un peu obscurci et d'une révolution
ça fait la glaciation ça fait une
glaciation
ou s'il n'avait pas une conjonction de l
ina apprendra qu'on peut importe joly
est un phénomène climatique qui amène d
un bouleversement alors les il paraît
que le port de marseille étaient pris
par les glaces
ouais bon donc glaciation voilà alors
c'est connu des historiens qui ont parlé
la petite aire glaciaire réserver
l'accueil et lui dit si on regarde les
choses dans l'immédiat tout de suite à
chaud c'est l'horreur on tue les juifs
on vole les sorcières il ya de la
violence il ya des gens qui exagèrent
foyer
puis des gens qui d'éric hély qui dérive
qui dérape il passe tout seul je dis au
bout de 50 ans ou 100 ans la conséquence
de tout ça c'est ça le bouquin la
conséquence de tout ça c'est que dans
deux ou trois pays on va vraiment
inventé la modernité aux pays bas en
angleterre et donc les nouvelles idées
et la philosophie oran dans la modernité
et donc si vous avez le nez sur le
guidon de la très courte durée vous ne
pouvez pas imaginer ça mais si vous avez
le recul historique pas vous dites c'est
autre chose donc pour vous répondre oui
j'arrive à votre question pour vous
répondre
acceptons l'idée que nous ne saurons que
dans 50 ou 100 ans ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui tout ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui ça valait qu'on ne sait rien
et que aujourd'hui on voit certaines
choses on va peut-être quand vous venez
de le faire plus tôt les choses
inquiétantes où on est peut-être naïf
sur certaines choses qui nous semblent
positives mais que ça ne nous dit rien
sur le mouvement général historique dans
lequel on est on est placé ou
insuffisamment alors oui il ya des
choses très inquiétante là dessus je
suis tout à fait la grève mais en même
temps je vois des choses positives vous
donner un exemple de nom-domaine moi je
suis
sociale des mouvements sociaux comme ça
j'ai été formé à ça ça m'intéresse alors
qu'est ce que je vois je vois qu
effectivement les mouvements sociaux
dans l'ensemble pendant toute cette
période ils vont maïs radicalistes
s'adonnent les gilet jaune ça donne des
choses comme ça d'avoir le jugement
qu'on veut sur le gilet jaune c'est
autre chose mais c'est quand même pas
quelque chose qui nous propulse vers le
futur hockey
parce que ce sont des gens qui disent on
veut pas être les laissés pour compte du
changement à des gens qui voulaient pas
été laissés pour compte du changement
qui disent ne pas finir le mois j'ai
plutôt de la sympathie pour ces gens là
mais c'est pas des gens qui disent on va
construire un autre monde mais gilet
jaune ne vous ont jamais promis de nous
faire rentrer dans une nouvelle période
historique c'est bon alors que le
mouvement voyez dans le temps disait des
lendemains qui chantent demain ça sera
merveilleux on va construire un autre
monde mais mais mais qu'est ce qui s'est
passé aussi pendant toute la période
actuelle qu est ce qu ont depuis
quelques années
pleins d'expérience partout mais partout
où pas au palais dans un quartier dans
un villa ou si vous êtes un peu attentif
vous voyez pas une association des gens
qui inventent et gens qui communiquent
autrement qu'ils cultivent qui autrement
qui moi je ces derniers jours j'ai vu
deux ou trois copains on ignorait
complètement qu'ils avaient un jardin
premièrement et qu'en plus il faisait il
cultivait de façon hyper écolo ayant
pour aller vite mon pote c'est
impensable pour moi de
gassin kankan en connaissant ces gens là
vous avez des gens qui contestent et
pendant le coc vide le confinement l'efb
la période la plus dure ça n'a pas
empêché les gens de se mobiliser sur le
climat cela n'a pas empêché des gens se
mobiliser sur le racisme ou vous
rappeler cette manifestation dans la
foulée de la sphère georges floyd il ya
deux ans et en france pendant le
confinement une grosse manifestation
pour un inca 2
d'un jeune noir qui était qu'on avait
retrouvé mort celui ci dans une
gendarmerie ou un commissariat le
concept gendarmerie bon dans des
conditions assez suspecte bon et je suis
moins 10000 20000 personnes dans la rue
alors qu'on n'avait pas le droit de
manifester
balbronn donc il se passe des choses
quand mais voyez que moi je trouve très
très positive donc vous pensez contre
vous maintenant allons-y bien qu'elles
sont qu'elles sont des choses que vous
trouvez très négative et qui amènerait
un basculement mais dans le mauvais sens
alors je vais vous dire les raisons il
ya des gens qui nous font rentrer
reculons et de façon très négative
dans ce nouvel univers et moi je les je
les vois surtout du côté de tout ce qui
est fait qu news complotisme et je vais
être plus précis parce que ça c'est
facile à dire j'avais plus petits tous
ces gens qui disent je suis en sécession
avec la raison je suis en c c et je
m'expliquais mais ce que je suis en
sécession avec la vérité j'ai ma vérité
tu as ta vérité c'est pas la même bon
alors est plate et machin pourquoi lors
pourquoi ça m'inquiète c'est pas que il
ya toujours eu des gens comme ça et je
dirais même que parmi les gens qui sont
pas comme ça l'a toujours eu comme un
petit regard intéressé par sa 308 euros
avait une voyante donc et ça
l'intéressait donc au rayon du mois non
non après pat ami imaginaire jamais
jamais mais moi ah bon c'est choses très
personnelles mais puisqu'on a le temps
de parler j'en dis un mot mais on
passera à autre chose moi j'ai perdu un
enfant à l'âge de 4 ou 5 ans et c'était
une telle injustice que ça m'a vacciné
définitivement dans l'idée qu'il puisse
y avoir à dieu voilà pour parce que
c'était insupportable enfin la
parenthèse mais c'était pour vous
répondre à temps dans laquelle qu'est ce
que tu crois en dieu c'est pas rien donc
je ferme la parenthèse est donc
ce qui m'inquiète c'est quoi c'est ce
que je vois dans cette mouvance qu'on
peut appeler facilement complotistes des
gens qui disent moi j'ai accès internet
moi j'ai accès à la science moi j'ai
accès à eau des études parmi les plus
sérieuses qui soient moi je sais comment
comment se fait la recherche médicale
sur des gens qui accèdent à la
connaissance
souvent de manière comme des
autodidactes c'est quoi le proverbe
chinois par rapport à ça c'est avoir un
livre 100 m c'est dangereux c'est sa
hache que le poste revers mais je pense
que ja c'est là quelque chose de vrai
mais c'est respectable que des gens
veuillent se construire eux mêmes de
cette manière là simplement à quoi ça
aboutit c'est abouti balle anti
vaccination radical bons mots j'ai comme
tout le monde je suis je suppose que
c'est pareil pour tout le monde on en
connaît tous des gens qui sont anti
vaccins gers et ça s'explique c'est bon
mais quand ça prend un tour complotistes
quand ça prend un tour de guerre quand
ça prend un tour de gemma vérité les
autres ne l'ont pas et c'est là on
rentre dans des moments où notre société
soft fracture complète vous expliquer
ces mouvements là c'est une carence du
système éducatif
c'est une carence du système
journalistique au médiatique c'est le
fait que les politiques ont raconté
tellement de billevesées depuis
certaines années que il ya une défiance
et que les scientifiques en faillite
alors moi j'ai beau expliquer vie de
réfléchir comme ça c'est à dire que mon
type de raisonnement il est pas celui là
donc ça m'est difficile mais je vais
rentrer dans votre raisonnement
évidemment question c'est pas mal dans
la zone rouge mais si parce que ça votre
question elle induit une façon de
réfléchir elle si elle a dit je vais
chercher les causes
je vais chercher vous restez sur les
effets non c'est pas ça mais moi j'ai
j'essaie d'avoir la vision suivante du
berger c'est chez me dire on est sorti
dans les années soixante ou soixante-dix
d'un vieux monde
un vieux monde qui avait plutôt
confiance dans la science qui respectait
plus tôt les enseignants dans lequel
quand il y avait de la recherche
médicale ou scientifique puisque c'est
ça me joue par lé respect et on ne
mettait pas ça en cause vous pouvez
s'inquiéter des dégâts de ça où on
pouvait dire je veux jamais un tout
petit exemple je veux un autre rapport
avec ceux qui produisent la connaissance
moi j'avais été très intéressés c'est
dans les années 70 par un petit bouquin
qui s'appelait le guide des 100
médicaments les plus usuels quelque
chose comme ça du docteur pradal tout le
monde a oublié ça c'est un petit bouquin
qui qui proposait donc une centaine de
médicaments avec des fiches en gros pour
vous dire voilà à quoi ça sert houle à
quoi ça sert pas voilà quand c'est
dangereux même de le proposer etc qui
fait que vous alliez chez le médecin et
si le médecin vous disais ah bah vous
avez tel problème je vous prescrire tel
ou tel
ou tel médicament si dans ce cas là vous
si vous aviez lu le guide des
médicaments aussi vous y aviez accès
menant docteur c'est pas possible
regardez ce qu'ils disent et du donc ça
modifie le médecin était plus sacrés si
vous voulez oui on est rentré dans une
époque où le rapport à la connaissance
la médicale mais pas seulement c'est à
évoluer mais ça c'était ces années 60 70
80 aujourd'hui on est au delà de ça on
est dans des dents un dans une période
où tout a changé donc je pousse le
domaine de la science mais on m'a
reproché récemment
d'être vieux jeu de m'intéresser qu'on
vieux vieilles associations vieux
syndicats non mais ça a existé on peut
en parler celle du siècle dernier on a
dit oui bon après tout c'est vrai ben
may mais
je sais aussi réfléchir à son avec un
peu plus de distance et me dire dans
l'évolution actuelle il ya des logiques
de rupture avec la connaissance avec la
vérité et avec le débat et avec la
culture de l' échange et ça c'est très
grave et donc les où sont les
responsabilités elles sont un peu
partout si je vous dis les gilet jaune
c'est un bon exemple sur les conditions
sur les antilles vax alors les antivols
d'accord on continue sur les anti
vaccins bon sûr je vais me faire
l'avocat du diable mais il faut y aller
mais attendez moi je fais partie des
gens qui reproche à emmanuel macron
d'avoir dit j'emmerde j'emmerde les anti
vaccins
je pense qu'il a eu tort comme président
et sur le fond même et comme eux il
s'appelle votre dernier bouquin il
s'appelle alors monsieur alors monsieur
macron heureux et je le critique de là
dessus au passage il continue et donc le
le la question si vous voulez de ce
mouvement
c'est que à partir de du désir de
maîtriser son propre corps sa propre
existence peut-être sujet on en arrive à
être dans des logiques de rupture avec
une grande partie de la société alors
qui est responsable
ben oui bien sûr il ya peu tu as tu des
journalistes ont mal fait leur boulot
quand été arrogant et et qui croyait
tout savoir qu'ils croient qu'on connaît
la société parce qu'on passe à vidot un
ordinateur on peut critiquer le monde
des médias et salons parisiens ou dans
les salons parisiens m'envoya aussi des
bons journalistes qui font du bon boulot
faut pas non plus exagérer bon c'est
limité 1 bien sûr bien sûr bon alors on
est bon on a critiqué les enseignants
les chercheurs les intellectuels les
politiques alors on a toujours des
bonnes raisons de faire taire ses
critiques si vous prenez la critique des
politiques c'est vrai qu'il ya de la
corruption en politique peut-être moins
qu'ailleurs mais il y en a c'est vrai
que les politiques sont pas très sérieux
c'est vrai que les politiques qui sont
un jour ceci un autre jour cela ça fait
partie de la vie politique donc il
arrive un moment où pour des bonnes
raisons en sont on est en opposition
avec ce monde d'en haut si vous voulez
pour des bonnes raisons mais parfois
aussi pour des mauvaises raisons mais
qui a tort mais tout le monde a un peu
tort ou tout pourquoi est-ce qu'on monte
aux extrêmes pour qu'on accepte la
dissociation des choses pourquoi est ce
que on ne veut plus discuter pourquoi
que tient quand on nous propose de
discuter ça ne marche pas c'est là où il
faut commencer à s'interroger et je
pense et c'est pour ça que je raisonne
un peu différemment de simplement la
recherche de ce genre d'explications je
pense que tout ça c'est un moment
historique qui est lié au fait qu'on est
sortis d'un vieux monde et comme sait
pas encore très bien de quoi sera fait
le nouveau monde qu'on est dans une
espèce d'entre deux à vrai dire c'est
facile de dire ça mais moi je pense
qu'on on n'a pas fini de sortir du vieux
monde dont le sommet pour moi était les
années 50-60 si vous voulez on est en
train d'entrer dans autre chose et dans
cet autre chose il se construit des
trucs formidables intéressante pour elle
je vous parlais moi les gens qui se
mobilisent sur le climat je trouve ça
formidable j'ai donc le féminisme en
france est très faible bon pour être
beaucoup plus actif et beaucoup plus
constructif il est très défensif juste
titre agressif ou agressif agir on
comprend aussi mais moi j'aimerais qu'on
me dise grâce au féminisme on va
introduire d'autres rapports entre les
gens on va introduire des nouvelles
formes de vie culturelle de on va penser
l'amour autrement la sexualité autrement
et c'est ça ça m'intéresse plus que ce
qui est crucial c'est à dire les femmes
sont soumis à des violences terribles et
c'est quand même une urgence donc voila
et donc si vous voulez on est dans cet
entre-deux c'est comme ça que je
réfléchis et donc moi ce qui m'intéresse
et qu'est ce qui se construit et m'avait
posé la question tout à la danse qui se
construit face à ce qui se construit
dans ce nouveau monde il ya aussi des
forces inquiétante et donc les anti
vaccins qui sait des gens très moderne
d'une certaine façon ils vous parlent de
vaccination il étudie la science la
médecine ils savent plein de choses ils
savent beaucoup beaucoup de choses et
puis en même temps ils peuvent déraper
complètement refusé de le dialogue mais
avoir le sentiment qu'on refuse de
dialoguer avec eux aussi ses
séquelles sont leurs arguments
mais leurs arguments sont scientifiques
et subjectif scientifique
fait l'expérience essayez de vous dire
voilà je je veux trouver des arguments
qui vont me permettre de montrer que la
vaccination ne s'est pas une bonne chose
vous allez sur les laboratoires à
l'homme condamné pour x y ou n'en sait
si cette expérience qui ont si c'est on
ne fait même c'est qu'on ne parle pas
des recherches qu'ils qui montre que
c'est une mauvaise chose on n'en parle
pas assez c'est une bonne chose ou que
c'est on parle trop des recherches qui
disent que c'est une bonne chose on ne
nous écoute pas certains médecins qui
sont pourtant des gens regardez la
sphère raul très intéressant on a pu
dire à juste titre c'est marseille
contre paris le type il est il est
souvent un peu baratineur et ben moi je
suis pas du tout de son côté mais il ya
quand même beaucoup de gens qui est
convaincu cran qui me oui mais qui sont
convaincus que c'est un grand savant et
qui etc et que c'est un grand
scientifique et à ce titre là il est
victime de gens qui veulent pas lui
laisser une place donc donc si vous si
vous voulez par lui mentais contre la
vaccination et que pour la vaccination
ou pour la vaccination dans les deux cas
si vous allez si vous êtes tout seul si
vous allez sur internet mais vous
croulez sous les trucs et si vous êtes
un autodidacte malheureusement vous ne
savez pas faire le tri vous ne savez pas
ce qui est sérieux ce qui n'est pas
sérieux
voilà et donc je pense que les anti
vaccin c'est de cela que je peux
maintenant je pense que les antilles
vagues ce sont des gens qui sont
propulsés dans ce nouveau monde déjà ils
sont dans ce nu c'est pas le vieux
mentir et c'est pas des gens qui dit je
suis pour la sauce chili où je suis
bourget le char est à ninon c'est des
gens qui disent au nom de la raison au
nom de la connaissance au nom de la
science je pense qu'il faut réfléchir
autrement et mais qui à mon avis dérape
et donc sais pas si je le dis clairement
mais je pense que c'est entrer dans un
nouveau monde ça passe par des choses
comme ça qui peuvent devenir très
inquiétante je vais prendre un autre
exemple alors là il ya eu ce mouvement
qui s'appelait la manif pour tous
c'était un mouvement réactionnaire
à propos de du mariage des homosexuels
et il y avait aussi des inquiétudes sur
la procréation et sur l'adoption surtout
sur l'adoption et surtout cela tu mens
donc ce mouvement a des côtés totalement
réactionnaire et on y retrouvait les
secteurs les plus réactionnaires du
monde catholique et pas seulement ok
mais en même temps les thèmes sur
lesquels ils se situent ces des nouveaux
thèmes c'est des thèmes nouveaux c'est
la procréation médicalement assistée bon
c'est un certain nombre de choses liées
aux progrès les plus nouveaux de la
médecine de la science donc d'un côté
ils incarnent des choses que je n'aime
pas et d'un autre côté ils sont
installés déjà en partie paradoxalement
ces gens qui sont tellement réac dans le
nouveau monde c'est intéressant et c'est
comme ça je les considère alors pourquoi
ça se met en place comme ça se développe
là on en d'autres choses mais c'est ça
l'idée que vous présentez vous parler
d'islam gauchistes ces quads islamo
gauchiste ohlala là vous me faites
ouvrir un autre hymne du coq
aux ânes mais oui mais vous faites
passer là vraiment à tout un tout autre
registre mais alors vous voulez
continuer un petit peu l'ancien registre
on peut continent mais ça m'intéresse à
discuter avec vous de l'islamo gauchisme
parce que c'est des choses a été mêlé à
tout ça pourquoi district schiste alors
le mot lui-même au début a été forgée
pour autre chose que ce à quoi il sert
eux aujourd'hui il a été forgée en gros
utiliser en tout cas dans un contexte
qui était contact des années 2000 quand
il y avait un prédicateur tariq ramadan
qui qui était un peu la coqueluche de
certaines personnes ou rien et de
certains médias à gauche on a beaucoup
reproché car mourad avoir débattu avec
lui justement est donc et donc c'était
l'idée si vous voulez que il ya une
gauche complaisante qui s'est fait
rouler dans la farine par des gens qui
finalement roule pour un islam radical
céder à l'idée de l'époque mais ça a
pris un autre tour plus récemment et là
il faut que que je vous présente le jeu
excusez je vais jargonner un peu le
système sémantique c'est lens c'est à
dire un tout un nouveau vocabulaire dont
fait partie l'islamo gauchisme
c'est-à-dire cornucopia corps du copiant
cornucopia à je connais pas l'expression
on continue comme là bas c'est vous qui
devez aime le dire vous en fin
d'émission discutera que vous me direz
ce que c'est que le corps du coca bon
cop yayisme si je me trompe pas bon
qu'est ce qui s'est passé alors d'abord
le mot islamo gauchiste d'abord c'est un
mot très mauvais y compris du bonus ceux
qui l'utilisent moi je n'aime pas
évidemment pourquoi parce que c'est pas
islamisme au gauchisme c'est islamo donc
ceux qui critiquent critique l'islam et
les musulmans et pas simplement
l'islamisme et les islamistes il dénonce
l'islamo gauchisme fois plus que vous
ben si j'avais été comme eux j'aurais
appelé ça l'islamisme au gauchisme mais
ça c'est la première moitié des choses
et la deuxième moitié gauchisme
qu'est-ce qui vise mais c'est pas les
gauchistes sépare les trotskistes de
chez même plus comment ça s'appelle npa
non ce qui vit c une partie de la gauche
donc il aurait dû appeler ça l'islamisme
au de gauche ou quelque chose comme ça
voyez donc d'un côté islam is et
généralise en parlant d' islam et pas
d'islamisme et d'un autre côté ils
réduisent en parlant de gauchisme alors
qu aurait été si une bonne partie de la
gauche qui sont dans le radar donc oui
c'est un mode bon et puis en plus dire
que l'université c'est un paradis pour
l'islam gauchisme c'était une connerie
sans nom et la ministre vidal qui a dit
ça j'allais dire paix à son âme
on l'avait a pu
rue descartes au ministère c'est très
bien comme ça et donc c'était des
bêtises mais c'est une campagne
compliquée qui s'est mise en place et
qui a trouvé qui est montée en force
depuis trois ou quatre ans alors qu'est
ce qu'il ya dans cette campagne pour ça
que je dis c'est un un système de mots
assist mc menti mot valise pour
discréditer pour l'art ça sert à
discréditer mais c'est ça vient avec
d'autres on a dénoncé aussi le crocis
mhz alors en france personne n'avait
jamais entendu ce mot pratiquement faire
s'agit quand même se dire oui à même pas
ce que vous vous êtes allé aux états
unis que vous connaissez le monde
américains mais enfin c'est un mot rêver
raison c'est du mauvais anglais
qu'utilisent les noirs américains pour
10 réveille toi que soit conscient ou
est réveillée comme c'était ça mais ça a
été très vite
disqualifiée aux états unis et encore
plus ceux qui l'ont importé en france
c'est en réalité un mot qui permet de
désigner des excès des dérapages au nom
d'une identité de minorités raciales
pour le dire vite autrement dit c'est
une façon de dire le walkie c'est l'idée
qu' il ya de l'intolérance et que cette
intolérance elle est voulue par des gens
qui excite un petit peu la conscience
des des acteurs dans des dans les
universités ou ailleurs donc le walk it
vous êtes-vous kyste si vous voulez
empêcher
un conférencier venait venir dire dans
votre université que la colonisation n'a
pas fait que des dégâts ben voilà c'est
le mot qui ça va avec l'idée de
cancelles culture la culture de
l'annulation
contre que les mêmes critiques sans voir
que dans cette culture dite de
l'animation il ya des gens qui mettent
en avant les problèmes intéressants vous
donne un exemple si vous voulez
moi en bon élève enfin ne lève pas si
bon que ça lui enlève pas trop mauvais
dans le secondaire j'avais appris que
colbert était un grand ministre parce
que en gros l'état colbertiste il avait
développé l'économie qui avait fait de
la france un grand pays économie voilà
tu disais à colbert pour moi il a fallu
que des gens disent quand celle culture
culture de l'animation arrêtez de nous
parler de colbert c'était un [__] le
code de l'esclavagé le code noir c'est
lui bon alors après les uns des
historiens ont dit c'est pas si simple
que ça mais ben voila moi j'ai découvert
cet autre face quand même dû du
personnage et donc la cancel culture
elle est très inquiétante quand elle
détruit purement et simplement elle est
moins inquiétante elle est utile quand
elle attire l'attention sur un problème
ou sur un an donc on a reproché à legend
est islamo gauchiste on a reproché à
d'autres ou au même d'être homo christ
on leur a reproché d'être dans la cancel
culture on la rend plancher de faire des
études des colonials et des études
postcoloniales sans savoir faire la
différence entre les deux je peux vous
faire un cours qui serait un peu
ennuyeux mais en gros des études des
colonials c'est des études qui se
réclame d'un certain marxisme est qui et
qui met en relation la colonisation et
capitalisme pour simplifier bon alors
que les études c'est pas des coups mais
je trouve ça très intéressant j'ai eu
des très bons amis qui faisaient des
choses très intéressantes au pérou
notamment et donc
les études postcoloniales par contre
tout ce qui est unie la colonisation la
décolonisation et terrasson un pack bon
ya pas que des gens qui déconne
lancement ces trucs là au contraire des
historiens en particulier ou des
ethnologues les politologues qui font
des travaux très très intéressant aussi
bon donc si vous voulez si mis en place
voilà une critique et puis je pourrais
en rajouter à huy dans cette critique on
a dénoncé aussi ceux qui utilisaient le
concept d' intersectionnelle it et sans
savoir ce que c'était que ce concept je
peux vous en dire un mot
c'est la personne qui l'a forgé c'est
une juriste féministe noire américaine
comment kimberley qui mairie crèche
crenshaw c'est une femme qui s'est
aperçu un jour dans ses recherches est
plutôt juridique elle s'est aperçue je
simplifie que quand on regarde la façon
dont sont traités les femmes noires
pauvres par le système de justice
américain ce qui leur arrive je vais le
dire comme ça c'est plus que la simple
somme des discriminations qui vous
arrive parce que vous êtes femme ou
parce que vous êtes noir ou parce que
vous êtes pauvres c'est quelque chose de
plus compliqué c'est plus lourd encore
donc l'intersexualité c'est l'idée qu'on
va étudier ce qui se joue quand il ya
intersections de plusieurs problèmes de
plusieurs discrimination demande ici
vous êtes fan noir handicapés pauvre
musulmane moche puis à bompas et bien
vous vos souffrances vos difficultés
dans l'existence c'est plus que la
simple somme de ce qui arrive pour
chacune de ces catégories en gros alors
je dis pas que c'est un concept génial
mais moi je me suis souvenu quand on a
commencé à critiquer ça c'est ce que
disait angéla davis en juillet à 40 en
classe race
bon et donc on s'est mis à dire c'est un
concept très dangereux tout simplement
parce que ce qu'ils le brandissent est
était effectivement parfois un peu
déconné parce qu'une chose est
d'utiliser un concept et une autre chose
c'est de
de faire de la politique en disant voilà
mon concept est donc on a critiqué ça
donc ça fait partie de ce système
sémantique et puis à huy dans ce système
sémantique ya aussi l'écriture inclusive
bon jeu l'écriture inclusive je le dis
franchement ça me casse les pieds je
suis pas du tout bon enfin de l' enfer
le diable alors ce sont les mêmes qui
ont critiqué tout ça en même temps et au
nom de quoi c'est qui ceux là alors je
vais vous dire ce sont des gens qui
peuvent être de gauche comme de droite
comme d'extrême droite donc c'est pas
juste c'est pas politiquement un groupe
précis ce sont des intellectuels des
journalistes des hommes politiques et le
sommet de tout ça est apparu qu'en 2
ministre des manuels macro ont dit on et
de ce côté-là blanc caire et vidal quand
deux ministres nous disent on dénonce
l'islamo gauchisme on dénonce le web qui
se met tout ça alors là ça donnait une
caution au plus haut niveau de la
politique française à ce mouvement dont
maintenant je vais vous expliquer si
vous voulez bien les tenants et
aboutissants
en simplifiant à l'extrême mais c'est
que c'est très important pas trop le
simple et course alors je prends mon
temps on va voir je m'étale même un peu
les mêmes qu'en cdi parce que sinon
c'est le slogan ou le passeport pour le
slogan idéologie alors c'est pas mon
style mais mais comment dire je sais
aussi que écouter quelqu'un c'est plus
fatiguant que de parler donc moi je
parle c'est pas trop fatiguant et genton
dormir avec vous soutenons mais les gens
qui m'écoutent il tentait besoin d'un
peu de bon alors en gros si vous voulez
ce qui rassemble tout ce monde-là
revient nous renvoie un problème général
d'une démocratie dans une démocratie
vous avez deux choses vous avez d'un
côté la totalité à l'inter de laquelle
les choses se jouent c'était un principe
d'unité on forme un tout la démocratie
elle se fait au niveau d'une ville où il
se fait au niveau surtout d'un pays la
méta donc il ya un cadre qui fait une
totalité premièrement et deuxièmement la
démocratie c'est ce qui permet de
traiter les problèmes sans violence en
principe avec un minimum de viol qui
permet de débattre tout ce dont on
parlait tout à l'heure la culture du
débat de les changements alors on est
dans un moment où des gens cherchent un
principe d'abord d'unités qu'est ce qui
fait qu'on est tous ensemble
et bien le principe d'unité que certains
mettent en avant c'est la nation ils
sont nationalistes
donc au nom de la nation tout ce qui va
pas
justifier un programme politique du
genre marine le pen pour simplifier ou
eric zemmour si vous préférez mais
d'autres et c'est cela dont je suis en
train de vous parler ne met pas vraiment
en avant la nation il vous disant
l'unité c'est la république ces valeurs
de la république
c'est la laïcité c'est cet ensemble de
choses qui font qu'on a une sorte de
pacte entre citoyens pour vivre ensemble
une très belle idée simplement cette
idée quand elle est brandie par les gens
dont je suis en train de vous parler
elle s'accompagne de l'idée que tout ce
qui compte est protestent et cetera se
ramène aux pires horreurs dues au cusm
de l'islamo gauchisme des études des
colonials etc etc faut dire que c'est
mon pool alors de des billets alors vous
avez raison mais c'est là où il faut
être précis vous avez raison il ya des
excès des dérapages des bêtises des
conneries des choses inacceptables
bah vous comprenez je déteste qu'on
empêche un spectacle d'avoir lieu
je déteste qu'on interdise un
conférencier de venir s'exprimer sont
fichés vraiment le dernier des fascistes
ou bon donc mon donc et des excès et à
l'intolérance et du de ce côté là il ya
des appels à l'identité on se replie sur
son identité et ont fait du racisme au
nom de sa propre identité ça existe
aussi donc il est plein d'excès je ne le
conteste pas du tout mais faut pas jeter
le bébé avec l'eau du bain et c'est ça
autrement dit ce courant dont je vous
parle mais on pourrait compliquer une
analyse il vous dit vive la république
une indivisible
au passage dans la constitution ya pas
marqué une et indivisible contrairement
à ce qu'on croit vive la république une
et indivisible donc une qui forme à tous
et au nom de sa tout ce qui bouge c'est
du groupe kiss me fait du slam au
gauchisme et où je ne veux pas en
entendre parler et donc c'est une rue
une sorte de rétraction de
radicalisation
autour de l'idée de république c'est
donc pas la même chose que l'extrême
droite même si ça peut prendre un tour
extrême et donc c'est ces questions là
qui ont culminé alors qu'elle est le
coeur de tout ça et j'en arrive à
l'islamo gauchisme
oui le
excusez-moi dudu du long chemin le coeur
de tout ça c'est la hantise de l'islam
s'ils avaient pas la hantise de l'islam
toutes ces questions serait serait
secondaire ou non elle n'aurait pas
l'impact que ça et donc ce qui soude ces
gens que j'appellerais public and east
c'est à dire qu'ils utilisent l'idée de
république d'une façon que moi je crois
excessive ce qui les soude c'est la peur
de l'islam ce qui fait la tenez vous
bien ce qui va perdre l'identité
française pour non ça c'est les autres
scellés ça c'est le côté marine le pen
c'est le côté front national
rassemblement national qui vous dit où
ou plus encore marion maréchal c'est à
dire
l'identité française est menacée le
grand remplacement et ces trucs-là bon
mais eux qui peut être d'un peu de ce
côté là mais c'est pas ça vraiment eux
ils vous disent la république est
menacée
alors ils peuvent ça peut être parfois
les mêmes qui sont à la fois
nationaliste et républicanisme oui c'est
pas exactement le même ils sont pas sous
le même poussant même combat et ce qui
fait qu'ils ont une caractéristique est
constante que j'ai vu pape ces gens là
sont en lutte active contre
l'antisémitisme
j'ai pas tout à fait la tasse de thé du
rassemblement national
bon ils sont en lutte actifs mais
pourquoi j'ai été voir ça de très près
parce qu'il considère que
l'antisémitisme
aujourd'hui en france c'est avant tout
la sphère des musulmans ça vient avant
non mais c'est ce qu'il pense à moi
j'suis pas d'accord avec ça déjà je
conteste complet mais voyez si vous
pouvez donc ils sont dans la hantise de
l'islam ils peuvent dire qu'ils sont
qu'il lutte d'autant plus activement
contre l'antisémitisme que l'islam c'est
les territoires perdus de la république
c'est
finalement les vrais antisémites les
vrais problème d'antisémitisme se joue
de ce côté là et donc les gens qui ont
théorisé l'idée qui est nouvelle
judéophobie ou un nouvel antisémitisme
ils l'ont localisé la parfois en
ajoutant en ajoutant qu'une certaine
gauche étaient complaisantes par rapport
à ça bon mais vous voyez alors au
rendement des choses un peu un peu
compliqué qui me concerne peut-être
qu'une petite partie du monde des idées
ou du monde de la politique
mais c'est très important pourquoi parce
que si vous aujourd'hui et ça ramène à
nos question plus générale que vous
posiez tout à l'heure si aujourd'hui on
est dans un pays où on vous dit vous
avez d'un côté l'extrême droite
nationaliste
avec sa variante zemmour et sa variante
le pen pour simplifier
donc zemmour c'est plutôt identitaire et
le pen c'est à la fois identitaire et
sociale
le revenu
l'inflation est à dire qu'ils n'étaient
pas des thèmes à la zemmour donc j'ai
d'un côté cet extrémisme là moi je peux
pas en fait vous avez un autre ensuite
une autre radicalité qui se réclament de
la république le maquereau disque alors
non c'est ce que macron a laissé faire
en laissant blanquet et compagnie agir
et qui a laissé faire stratégie
politique je pense mais on va peut-être
finir parce que tout a changé d'un seul
coup et vous avez enfin des identitaires
vous avez des identitaires qui vous
disent par exemple on vous dit que je
suis noir et bien oui je suis noir et on
va se réunir entre noirs pour discuter
ensemble de deux de nos problèmes de
noir et après on va développer du
racisme anti blanc je prends un cas
extrême et qui n'existe presque pas mais
quand même un petit peu donc là on est
vraiment donc dans des logiques qui donc
les indigènes de la république ce genre
de groupes bon donc si vous voulez c'est
inacceptable aussi donc moi qui me sens
de la sympathie pour
les gens qui contestent qui sont contre
le racisme contre les discriminations je
peux pas rejoindre de tels groupes moi
qui suis très un enfant décor
républicaine de la laïcité je peux pas
rejoindre le discours des républicaines
east et moi qui suis plutôt content
d'être français qui sait que notre pays
c'est vraiment un beau pays qui sait que
on a de bonnes raisons d'être fiers
d'être français je suis pas nationaliste
et donc qu'est-ce que les patriotes
écouter
disons que je n'ai jamais eu à défendre
la patrie donc je ne sais pas s'ils
suent patriotes mais ce que je sais
c'est que quand on nous parlait de valmy
on a pendant la révolution française ça
me touchait expliqué pour les plus
jeunes alors valmy c'est une bataille
valmy en gros la révolution s calèche
qu'on est en 1791 et à ce moment
j'espère ne pas me tromper d'année et à
ce moment là les les
l'étranger
pour soutenir le roi pour soutenir la
royauté française et avait avec beaucoup
de gens qui sont qui ont quitté la
france justement parce qu'ils étaient
contre la révolution attaque la france
les armées étrangères attaque la france
et il ya une bataille à valmy dans
laquelle les patriotes révolutionnaire
l'emportent sur ses troupes étrangères
donc dans le pour moi c'est vraiment la
bataille de la patrie mais on peut
parler d'aujourd'hui j'ai comme presque
tout le monde énormément de sympathie
pour l'ukraine s'il ya bien du
patriotisme quelque part aujourd'hui
dans le monde dont le voilà donc donc je
suis pas un patriote au sens aux armes
citoyens
mais je comprends et j'accepte bien
l'idée de patriotisme voilà bon donc bon
donc voilà c'est ça un peu le paysage
que je voulais vous vous décrire il n'y
a pas que ça dans l'existence bien sûr
heureusement je vous parlais de macron
voulez vous que je suis un peu plus
précis ni longtemps d'accord nous reste
du temps
revenons sur l'islam gauchisme
ce mot valise pour discréditer tout
temps
c'est nouveau c'est pas nouveau dans
l'histoire est ce qu'on a utilisé des
mots valises pour discréditer des gens
oui non est ce qu on déboulonne les
les statuts est-ce qu'il faut
déboulonner les statues ou pas ou est ce
qu'il faut mettre une plaque explicative
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire alors bon sur
ce dernier point est la question
historique plus générale on essaierait
de le voir si ces cas choses à dire mais
sur ce point plus précis la jeune j'y
vois clair après moi même après on peut
ne pas être d'accord moi je pense que on
ne doit jamais détruire
ce qui existe c'est à dire une statue
doit pas la détruire une oeuvre d'art on
n'a pas la détruire une chanson on doit
pas l'interdire la musique de
tchaïkovski on l'a pas l'interdire et
c'est donc ça mais je pense aussi
que il faut tenir compte de ce que
véhicule la statue
la musique etc et que par conséquent il
faut en profiter lorsqu'un problème
apparaît elle ou devient conscient
lorsqu'on découvre quelque chose il faut
en profiter pour faire deux choses 1
montrer qu'on est sensible à la hausse
ou france historique de tel ou tel
groupe est de faire de la pédagogie
alors c'est quoi montrer qu'on est
sensible aux souffrances history si la
statue d'un personnage qui a participé à
l' esclavage et placés dans un endroit
où c'est choquant on peut peut-être la
déplacer la mettre dans un musée donc la
statue ne disparaît pas mais elle est
mise dans un endroit où en principe on
on vient voir les choses autrement que
quand on passe dans la rue devant une
statue et puis notre comprendre ou prou
le temps pour et deuxièmement exactement
on prend le temps d'expliquer donc si à
la limite la statue doit rester dans là
où elle est pour différentes raisons
peint pas à ce moment là et bien on met
devant des explications et en les
maintenant deux ans lang ou dans trois
langues si ça peut être utile de telle
sorte que la personne qui regarde qui
prêtent attention à ses statuts parce
que très souvent on fait pas attention
une statue mais la personne qui prêtent
attention à ses statuts voit très bien
de quoi il s'agit et apprend quelque
chose
il faut de la pédagogie et du j'allais
dire du bon goût voilà donc si on a ce
genre d'état d'esprit
je dis pas que c'est la réponse générale
1 mais si on a ce genre d'état d'esprit
respectez les souffrances historique des
gens qui disent écoutez voilà ce type là
il a esclavagisés mon peuple ou mais
lens est bon bon si on comprend ça d'un
côté et si on comprend d'un autre côté
qu'il faut faire de la de l'explication
de la pédagogie on doit pouvoir trouver
des chemins
qui qui concilie un peu des contraintes
peut apparemment contradictoires voilà
c'est un peu comme ça je réfléchis à
risque dans le passé on a détruit bâle
sans arrêt j'ai lu un jour un bouquin
qui m'a stupéfait alors comme j'ai lui a
longtemps je ne serai pas très précis
mais c'est un petit goût du bouquin sera
écoutèrent je m'appelle milan de
l'auteur c'est un psychanalyste need you
say me reviendrait mais ninon nom de
l'auteur ni donc du bouquin mais celle
ci est ce qu'il raconte vous avez hugo
vide un tout petit peu alors que je suis
vacciné à mort donc non je ne pense pas
avoir des défaillances de mémoire non
mais simplement si jamais vous lisez mes
bouquins puis quand mouvement mais le
bouquin raconte une chose incroyable
pendant la révolution française au
moment où la guillotine est le roi des
gens sont allés à la basilique de saint
denis pour exhumer les tombeaux les rois
qui était enterrée elle est une deuxième
fois
voilà donc c'est cool bah oui mais faut
être porté par quelque chose de très
spécial au donc oui à d'autres c'est
pour vous dire à d'autres époques il ya
eu des horreurs extrême quand même bon
donc que des gens et d'être que des
statues basse a toujours existé
évidemment évidemment egypte 1 j -pd par
cet exemple évidemment il ya aussi eu
des pillages alors c'est un autre aspect
de ces choses là c'est qu'on n'a pas
d'être des statuts relais appuyés par
exemple d'ailleurs bon non mais quand on
leur casser le nez
donc d'effacer ce genre de choquant août
à face et il n'y a pas si longtemps il
n'y a pas si longtemps et on n'a
personne n'a parlé de quand cette
culture est ce que vous n'avez pas le
souvenir de la guerre en irak quand la
statue de l'opération américaine de
l'ani filiation de propagande de
communication mais ils ont ils ont fait
tomber la statue de il s'appelait saddam
hussein de saddam hussein mais je revois
encore ces images où elle tombe par
terre bon personne n'a protesté seins là
je peux vous dire qu'on était pour
autant il ya toujours eu des gens qui
ont brisé dans les églises tout ça enfin
bon ça a toujours existé bien sûr bien
sûr
avant qu'on parle de monsieur bacrot
question internet ce monsieur at il eu
le livre comment la non-violence protège
l'état
car ce livre là non mais c'est une thèse
qui m'intéresse beaucoup
mais on peut le dire de deux façons
différentes à mon avis on peut dire la
non violence doit être une sorte
d'idéologie
je suis non violence presse la non
violence
j'ai beaucoup d'admiration pour ça je
pense que ce n'est pas la réponse aux
problèmes
je pense que la réponse à la violence
bon risque de violent tout ce qui est
prévention ou sortie de la violence j'ai
dirigé tout un programme de recherche
sur ces questions donc on a je peux vous
en dire quelques mots plus précis même
si vous voulez
bombay domitienne tu crois que tu dis si
pour vous cinq à dix
quand même donc mais
donc je pense que là les meilleures
réponses à ces questions empêcher la
violence il ne suffit pas de prôner la
non violence même si gandhi c'est
magnifique bon je pense ou où mandela ou
mandela bond vers les deux ont eu parce
que gandhi a vécu en afrique du sud
avant d'aller re nahd l'afrique du sud 1
5 kg en afrique je suis directement mais
je pense que là le plus important si on
veut éviter la violence c'est qu'il faut
transformer les logiques de rupture les
logiques de grande crise grecque et les
inquiétudes dont vous parliez tout à
l'heure il faut les transformer excusez
mon jargon en conflit institutionnalisée
c'est à dire en conflit où on reconnaît
des quais les points de vue opposés mais
on est discutée c'est ça la démocratie
et on les traite
je vous donne un exemple pour ça je
voulais vous parler pop un peu de la
sortie de lier très intéressant michel
avant qu avant l'exemple c'est pas un
peu de la poignée de sociologues ça a
pas du tout justement le goût donné je
me fais l'avocat du mal à vous avez tort
je suis pas d'accord total en zi jose
était d'accord mais là je suis là parce
que je vais vous parler de vraies choses
nos sources qui historiquement ont pesé
très lourd je ne suis pas jaloux donner
un exemple mais c'est un exemple très
parlant il ya quelques années ça marche
ça marche pas ce genre de choses dont je
vous parlais il ya quelques années il y
avait encore en colombie
une grande guérilla c'était la dernière
norme veille à l'amérique latine les
farc
et cette guérilla qui était un mélange
de guérilla et trafic de stupéfiants et
de drogues enfin cesser des gens c'est
un savez ces guérillas qui deviennent du
crime organisé un petit business voilà
du business mais qu'ils contrôlaient des
régions qui étaient très puissant
quelques partis politiques alors ils ont
accepté ils ont accepté un processus de
négociations alors pour qu'il y ait des
négociations et à des conditions il faut
qu'il ya un tiers qui met les acteurs en
présence il faut que ça se passe dans un
endroit où tout le monde se sente en
sécurité
il ya plein de conditions mais toujours
est il qu'un beau jour ils se sont
retrouvés à cuba le gouvernement
colombien et les représentants des facs
pour discuter on arrête alors évidemment
ça pose tout de suite la question de la
justice parce que arrêtés s'ils ont dieu
si la guérilla libre ok on arrête tout
on dépose les armes et on accepte d'être
de rentrer des gens vous dire bah
écoutez vers la bastille où un
mystérieux et dans ce cas là la justice
puisse connaître le contraire opposé
entrer en contradiction avec la paix
vous voulez la paix ok donc on va vous
analystes ont eu en contrepartie on vous
a mis ch'ti mais alors moi vous avez tué
dans mon village j'ai tué ma femme et
mes trois enfants et je vous ai ils vont
pas être jugé ces gens là c'est
insupportable donc c'est pas si simple
toujours est il qu'ils ont discuté ils
ont trouvé des solutions un certain
nombre de problèmes et que le plus
important ce qu'ils ont dit à la
guérilla le gouvernement colombien à dia
la guérilla on vous aide à vous
transformer en parti politique vous
aurez droit automatiquement un certain
nombre de postes député automatiquement
et en plus pour être candide de vivre
des gens de chez vous pourront être
candidats à des élections vous rentrez
dans le jeu institutionnel
et donc on transforme une situation de
violence de guérilla dans une situation
négociée bon ça a mal marché
malheureusement c'est pas un échec
complet mais c'est pas non plus une
réussite totale mais quand même et bien
c'est ça marche et c'est ça ben ça a mal
marché parce que parce que ces trucs
assez compliqué parce que tout le monde
n'est pas n'a pas envie que ça marche
savez souvent les négociations capotent
parce qu'il ya des gens qui les font
capoter de l'extérieur quand on va
regarder la sphère israélo
palestiniennes oslo ça négocie en
norvège grâce au norvégien on va vers un
on trouve une solution on trouve une
solution pratiquement et à ce moment là
assez vite ça tourne mal les attentats
et puis ça se termine avec l'attentât de
l'assassinât de rabin et puis c'est la
fin d'oslo bon mais ça marche pas
toujours mais quand ça marche c'est
quand même mieux c'est mais alors
pourquoi je vous dis tout ça c'est pour
vous dire moi je suis plus du côté de
ceux qui réfléchissent à transformer les
situations de violence de guerre guerre
civile de guérilla de terrorisme etc qui
cherchent à les transformer en conflit
se verra reconnaître qu'il ya un
problème mais qui est traitée
démocratiquement institutionnellement je
suis plutôt de ce côté là que du côté de
ceux qui croient que la non violence et
la réponse ça le poids mais mais mais ne
me faites pas dire que je ne dis pas je
trouve admirable les tentatives de
régler par la non violence des grands
problèmes et de ce point de vue là
mandela c'est quand même magnifique et
grouiller aussi comment vous voyez la
résolution du conflit ukrainien
même si c'est pas votre tasse de thé je
veux d'abord je veux que vous disiez
chaude j'ai vu trois jours avant que ça
pète les meilleurs politologue vous
expliquez que ça ne mettra pas donc
maintenant des pas de prévoir l'avenir
sur ça mais écoutez je j'imagine mal
et russe un putin acceptant de ne pas
obtenir certaines choses et j'imagine
mal et l'ukrainien acceptant une partie
du démantèlement de leur territoire donc
c'est une situation qui va durer parce
que je pense je pense qu'on en prend
pour un bon moment et que c'est le
contraire de la guerre froide la guerre
froide c'était pas la guerre on
contraire l'armé nucléaire car par proxy
ouais mais quand même dire il se tapait
pas dessus et je dirais même c'est à
pully pauvres avec des poudres ouais
mais même même ça évitait qu'un conflit
local prennent trop d'importance parce
qu'un conflit local qui aurait plus trop
qui commençait à prendre de l'importance
ça risquait d'entraîner au bout au bout
du compte parce qu'ils s'étaient
arrêtées en corée c'est à dire une
guerre entre les deux superpuissances
donc la guerre la guerre froide n'était
pas une guerre la fin des fusées à cuba
vous savez les missiles avec des têtes
nucléaires toutes ces choses là ils ont
trouvé
de quoi éviter le pied c'est intelligent
l'époque alors tout ce que j'ai pu lire
là dessus est très intéressant parce
qu'ils ont
on est à deux doigts il mais ils ont
trouvé
là pour qu'ils ont pu discuter parce que
ni le chef ni khrouchtchev ni kennedy
n'était isolé il est déconseillé et il y
avait un monde où on arrivait quand même
un peu à se parler
alors là pour l'instant qu'est ce que ça
se parle ou pas entre ukrainiens et
russes moi je ne sais pas les sentiments
que ça se parle peut-être avec des
intermédiaires mais un petit peu quand
même quand les prisonniers on les tue
pas quand ils peuvent sortis effet hier
bon temps qu'ils aiment tous peut-être
un tout petit espace mais pour vous
répondre je peux me tromper complètement
qu'en sortant de cette rencontre on
apprendra que qui est un accord qui
vient d'être signé donc oui on veut
toujours prudent de j'avais un prof qui
nous disait si vous êtes dans un service
de prévisions demandé la prévision à
long terme comme ça on aura oublié les
bêtises que vous aurais dit donc là je
suis prudent mais ce qui me semble le
plus vraisemblable c'est que la
situation dure gras bon moment
revenons à monsieur bah crew
pourquoi avoir déjà ce titre c'est quoi
ce titre
alors ça je suis coup city alors je vais
vous dire une chose ça m'est venu comme
ça mais ça m'est venu le titre avant le
contenu du bouquin
et pourquoi j'ai eu ses heures il ça
m'est venu en tête pour deux raisons
totalement différentes la première
moi j'aime bien les films qu'ils ont pas
toujours très fin ou très léger à bon
écoute et francky vincent ça va plus la
plus âgée mais donc il ya un film et
belmondo ou en gros là c'est dans mon
style c'est un vague souvenir mais la
scène c'est le match voilà le macho qui
demande à la fille ghislaine séduit
alors heureuse bon après on n'est pas
certain du tout que la fille a pris son
plaisir mais voilà est un film avec
marielle un peu comme ça aussi il les
galettes de pont-aven peut-être me
rappelle plus beaux mois et donc donc
c'est un truc qui me fait marrer quand
alors c'est donc c'est une façon de dire
a pas de palais je suis pas dupe on peut
pas être heureux dans une télé si on
peut on peut pas donc c'était une façon
de dire ouais je veux pas être dupe je
veux dire je veux pouvoir dire des
choses comme comme il faut les dire
votez macro prend du coup j'ai voté
maquereau au premier tour après alors
heureux et j'ai mon livre est sorti le
lendemain du deuxième tour donc je n'ai
pas participé par mon livre unis
autrement d'ailleurs à la campagne
présidentielle je voulais pas m'en mêler
je voulais pas donner des passes que
macro c'était pas un choix
comme pour beaucoup de gens c'était
quand même pas un choix d'ardon est
positive c'était j'ai la trouille de
voir autour des arrivées bon donc donc
je vais pas m'en mêler parce que je
trouve que ça c'était pas respectable de
de dire je vote pour quelqu'un mais je
n'ai pas vraiment envie qu'ils soient et
le club où tout le monde quand même non
j'ai pas pu faire partie
d'ailleurs que le dernier souvenir que
j'ai de gagner souvenir que j'élève a
appelé à voter pour quelqu'un je vais
vous dire c'était pour ségolène royal et
j'ai vu que j'avais dans le nez que
j'avais dans le nez et mon nom mais
amitié soixante huitarde je vous ai dit
mon beauf rcg sma vous serez pas étonnés
si jolie je suis très copain aussi avec
cohn bendit et à l'époque on me dit me
téléphonent huit jours avant l'élection
ségolène royal fric on pourront vous
emparer ensuite si vous vous laissez
jamais la petite histoire il me dit
écoute michel je lui fasse un article
dans le monde faut absolument que tu
soutiens de ségolène royal c'est pas
possible contre sarkozy
ben pour moi 68 c'était un tel moment
merveilleux dans mon histoire
personnelle et dans l'histoire de notre
pays que si comme le dit me dit michel
tu sois pas la fenêtre du sixième étage
je dis pas que je saute mais que je
réfléchisse avant lui dire non voyez bon
et donc il me dit ça donc là j'ai fait
un article dans le monde 8 jours avant
l'élection présidentielle
donc c'est un manque combien blanc
il ya très longtemps très longtemps pour
soutenir ségolène vrai mais j'ai pas pu
soutenir ardemment françois hollande
parce que j'ai jamais été son côté
jamais été et je pense que cet homme est
une catastrophe pour la gauche pour son
parti et pour les idées que qu'il aurait
pu incarner on peut le dire simplement
parce que il est arrivé au pouvoir il
avait tout la présidence même le sénat
la chambre des députés les régions et
herat et ça se termine 5 ans plus tard
parti socialiste est obligé de vendre
son siège parisien maintenant il n'y a
plus rien donc donc j'ai jamais tendre
et que j'ai appelé ardemment en tout cas
voter hollande mais là en tout cas dans
cette campagne à la dernière je n'ai
appelé à rien du tout et donc voilà donc
premièrement je viens ma môme et moutons
premièrement
je trouve
je trouve qu'il faut montrer que je ne
suis pas du poids j'ai envie de montrer
je suis pas du fait que je ne suis pas
un courtisan où je suis que je peux
discuter avec le chef de l'état voir
discuter l'interpeller sans être l'hiver
irrévérencieux mais on est un tout petit
est d'impertinence mai mais pas pour
m'aimer mais l'impatience qui ne casse
pas la possibilité de l'échanger pour
lui la pertinence de l'impertinent on
peut le dire comme ça c'est une belle
formule c'est une belle forme et les
pizzas avant d'aller me marc ulmann ah
ben on va très bien prêt
a été votre gourou presse que non
j'accepterai pas gourou je dirais bon
ton
et puis deuxièmement deuxièmement
on a de temps en temps au cours du
mandat de macron ressorti quelque chose
je les fais moi même d'ailleurs avec un
article dessus ressorti le thème des
jours heureux c'est à dire le titre un
moment donné du programme du conseil
national de la résistance et donc que
moi j'avais fait un article dans
libération macron avait utilisé
l'expression un autre jour et essai
revenait donc c'était aussi une façon de
lui dire vous nous avez promis des jours
heureux donc c'est avait aussi cette
référence là que j'avais en tête mais je
n'avais aucune idée du contenu de ce que
on pourrait mettre sous un tel titre moi
j'avais la formule en tête et j'en parle
à mon éditrice comme ça un jour au
téléphone à michel écrivait tout de
suite un bouquin là dessus
alors j'ai dit bon je réfléchir je vous
dis si j'ai quelques idées et je trouve
que j'avais accumulé parce que j'avais
j'avais écrit des choses par ailleurs
j'avais accumulé beaucoup d'idées et je
me suis aperçu que j'avais la matière
pour donner du contenu à ce qui était au
début simplement comme ça quoi un truc
qui vous traversent l'esprit du coup
balancé au téléphone à une amie mais
voilà c'est comme ça que ça c'est que ça
c'est fait et j'ai très bien compris
ensuite que ce que je voulais faire
c'était lui reprocher de ne pas avoir
été suffisamment dans le sens à la
démocratie c'est en fait c'est un ce
livre dont on pas servi vous j'ai voulu
défendre ni démocratique face à
quelqu'un qui a laissé un peu de
corruption s'installer autour de lui
proche de sa bon écoutez j'ai pris par
là j'ai puisé dans ce que disaient les
journaux et qu'il n'y a pas si je vous
dis benalla si je vous dis les gens qui
ont été mis en examen si et c'est bon
quand même avec mis en examen repose
maintenant attendez c'est ce que je dis
je le fais avec et du salon jeudi en a
qui sont pas coupables en tout cas pour
l'instant enfin responsable
je vous donne un exemple jardin
maintenant
jane harman alors j'ai fait il faut dans
mon bouquin que c'est la seule chose que
j'aie qu'on va faire et évoluent si mais
si c'est une maison d'édition belge est
alors monté alors ils sont merveilleux
on n'accepte pas les blagues logiciel a
nommé j'en ai une bien bonne à vous
raconter parce que c'est une maison
d'édition merveilleux mais ils m'ont
fait relire par un correcteur belge donc
pas fait attention à gérald plutôt que
gerra mais qui par contre un endroit je
suis utile ya le chiffre 90 qui apparaît
et la correctrice avait remplacé 90 et
l'avait mis 90
alors là heureusement j'ai pu relire la
les épreuves médias ne faut pas dire 90
pour un livre qui est destiné à un
public pas seulement francophones mais
plutôt français donc donc c'est quand
même plus logique ouais m'enfin ni vous
ni moi pour 10 90 ans génère donc j'ai
pu pour eux j'ai fait un coup vite vous
verrez avec moi j'ai oublié déjà j'étais
tout petit mais macron oui la corruption
la corruption bon mais c'est pas le plus
important dans ce que dans ce bouquin
enfin oui c'est ça gérald darmanin c'est
pour vous donner un exemple
s'est classé sans affaire avec cette
fille qui l'accusent de deux viols ou
presque ok ok je ne dis pas du tout qui
a essayé de la violer mais ce qui est
clair c'est qu'il a en quelque sorte
monnayer le pouvoir qu'ils avaient assez
dans les fonctions politiques qui
étaient les siennes à cette époque là
ils attendirent il a instrumentalisé
pour avoir des relations sexuelles avec
quelqu'un donc c'est pas brillant donc
c'est pas de la corruption lourde mais
moralement voilà c'est ça aussi ça
existe bon mais j'ai un cas très
intéressant
voilà enfin je lui dis moi en tout cas
c'est mais je cite comme ça j'ai pas
tout tout reprendre mais je cite la
sphère nicolas hulot alors il s'est
passé un truc je sais pas ça m'a coûté
tu combien d'euros innovation non non
vous allez voir je ne fais presque les
entrées le l'ancien secrétaire d'état à
la recherche thierry
beccaro
enfin bref c'est celle que celle qu'on
vit sûrement où c'est l'heure tardive
mais en tout cas le secrétaire d'état à
la santé michel thiry mandrichi mandon
demande on ment donc voilà décide de
créer un nouveau journal qui va
s'appeler l'hebdo donc ça m'a coûté je
suis plus 100 euros de 100 euros de
soutien parce que c'est quelqu'un pour
qui j'ai de l'estimé et de l'amitié et
créé ce nouvel journal et dans le
premier numéro de ce nouveau journal il
ya une enquête sur nicolas hulot et ses
affaires sexuelles bon
donc était peut-être passé vous et tout
court bon évidemment leurs qualités
l'enquêté peut être pas assez précises
ou faudra toujours est il que non
seulement
il est attaqué par le gouvernement mais
l'attaqué extrêmement violemment il se
fait traiter en semi privé par le chef
d'état de charognards pour avoir publié
sept 7 ans kate est vraiment sympa qui
défend ni tu l'aimés tous tous tout le
gouvernement à mort bah écoutez c'est
grave c'est grave dans ces cas là on est
plus prudent on dit attendre des preuves
et cetera l'orne pendant bon mais
défense du gouvernement salir de je ne
savais pas voilà donc voila voila donc
si vous voulez il ya tout un ensemble de
choses bon qui me semble poser problème
mais c'est pas le plus important de 2,2
ce bouquin c'est vraiment le le fait que
refus des corps intermédiaires refus les
médias tout syndicat
et puis il a couvert les affaires tout
ce dont on vient de parler d'islam en
gauchisme et tout ça il l'a laissé faire
jusqu'à aujourd'hui alors il s'est passé
un truc formidable
c'est que d'un seul coup nouveau
gouvernement élections législatives pour
le nouveau gouvernement ils virent les
deux ministres qui ont incarné cette
campagne bancaire et vidal il vire aussi
schiappa qui était pas très loin de tout
ça même si c'était sur un autre registre
plutôt les questions de genre et
hautement fin quand même et par ailleurs
il refuse main et ainsi de suite voilà
ma femme était un peu comme un peu comme
ça un peu comme blanc caire et sur une
ligne un peu de ce genre je trouve mais
surtout mais c'est surtout blanchir et
vidal quitter les personnages clés et
par ailleurs il refuse de l'investiture
de son parti à plusieurs personnes qui
sont dans cette nébuleuse que je vous ai
décrites du printemps républicain il
leur refuser l'investiture le seul à qui
il l'a laissée et ça fait un peu jaser
c'est manuel valls
républicains lui il est dans cette façon
de voir le monde il est pas associée
liste maman il a été au parti socialiste
il était pas espagnol il a été abattu en
des îles a été candidat aux élections
aux municipales en catalogne à barcelone
bien sûr aux municipales ou régionales
je sais plus frais payés il ya une très
belle chanson qu'on pense d'ailleurs à
bon ouais je m'appelle ben
may enfin en gros si mais sinon si vous
voulez il a coupé les ailes peut-être
provisoirement à ce mouvement que quand
j'appelle république à nice est pas un
mouvement c'est pas le party les
républicains c'est une idéologie qui
pervertit à mon sens l'idée de
république à c'est ça dont j'ai pas donc
il leur a coupé les ailes si les deux
ministres qui incarnait sasson j'irai
pratiquement si les gens qui voudraient
être député qui pourrait incarner cette
idée on peut le droit de se présenter
c'est quand même un camouflet
extrêmement fort qui est et donc on se
re et qu'est ce qui met en plus au
ministère de l'éducation nationale pap
ndiaye qui incarne évidemment le
contraire sur ce registre là de ce qui a
pu incarner blanc caire donc c'est un la
gifle est explicite en plus
qu'ici faites bien qu'ils dont macron
il nous a d'abord évité le pire mais il
il a évité le pire en y construisant
c'est très compliqué parce que pour
pouvoir être réélu il fallait qu'il a en
face de lui à fond pour être lu presque
à coup sûr il fallait qu'il ait en face
de lui marine le pen donc il nous a
évité marine le pen en étant élu mais en
même temps pendant cinq ans il a des
îles
il a facilité la montée du rassemblement
national toujours tous comme ça dit à
ben arfa mitterrand il était moins moins
gonflé quand même mais tel s'il était
gonflé il ya il est témoin mitterrand
pour affaiblir la droite a introduit la
proportionnelle bon ça c'est vrai mais
là ces a pris une proportion quand même
outre hautes vagues quand même 41 22%
pour marine le pen c'est quand même un
score impressionnant ça révèle quoi ça
bon moi je pense que ça révèle justement
le fait que notre pays est ingouvernable
parce que
gouvernable les français sondés vous non
non non et parce qu'il a ainsi entre
autres il est ingouvernable c'est pas
les seules places le problème mais notre
pays est ingouvernable
parce que son système institutionnel a
été construit pour un pays où il y
aurait deux forces politiques
importantes y en a trois ou deux les
blocs ou des ans c'est pas forcément des
blocs mais des enfants vous avez d'un
côté la gauche de la gauche d'un côté
la droite de la droite et l'extrême
droite et un troisième côté le centre ça
si je vous dis regardez résultat les
élections marine le pen
c'était combien c'était au premier tour
24 % je crois mélenchon 22 et macron
27 donc trois force presque pas qu'ils
jouent dans le même niveau à peu près
bon bah comment voulez-vous et les
forces inconciliables
si vous êtes mélenchon vous pouvez pas
aller faire affaire avec avec mâcon si
vous êtes le marine le pen vous pouvez
pas faire affaire avec lui donc a pas
d'alliances et encore moi me mélenchon
le pen dont il n'y a pas d'alliance
possibles dont vous êtes dans un système
très difficile à gouverner alors qu'est
ce qu'il a réussi très facile
instrumentalisée oui mais de façon enfin
c'est ça ne permet pas de le mobiliser
la société pour construire des choses
regardez l'allemagne avec des
difficultés c'est pas parfait mais en
allemagne et renforce qui sont mis
d'accord les libéraux les verts et les
sociaux démocrates
c'est très intéressant il se met
d'accord ils prennent le temps de
réfléchir ensemble de discuter de
d'élaborer ensemble un programme alors
qu'ils s'étaient eux un adversaire au
départ d'élaborer un programme de se
partager les responsabilités que tu
seras milices de ceci de cela et c et
puis ensuite la machine avance il ya pas
trop de couacs entre eux sur nous on
s'en va mais enfin bon ça marche mais en
allemagne le pouvoir représente 60 ou 65
% de l'électorat
en france on peut pas dire ça donc c'est
difficile alors vous me demandez qu'est
ce qu'il a fait de bien car je conclus
ce book mon bouquin en disant c'était
plutôt déséquilibrée vers la droite
votre affaire dans les cinq ans votre en
même temps qu'ils auraient dû être
équilibré mais il ya deux choses
positives que vous avez fait je lui dis
à ma kou 1 vous avez demandé à benjamin
stora qui est connu pour être un
historien de gauche est très très connu
pour ça vous lui avez demandé un rapport
sur les relations historiques entre la
france et l'algérie c'est très important
et c'est très bien ce qu'il a fait et 2
vous avez confié à pap ndiaye la
direction du musée ces panneaux exacte
du musée enfin du musée de l'immigration
de l'histoire de l'immigration donc ça
ces deux signes positifs que vous avez
envoyé à d'autres que la droite ou
l'extrême droite donc il a fait des
choses bien alors maintenant au delà de
ça c'est toujours les relais à faire don
dont je vous ai parlé ce soir mais
au-delà de ça je pense qu'il a plutôt
bien géré le coc vide après une période
de flottement
plutôt bien plutôt bien et que la france
s'en est plutôt bien sortie par rapport
à d'autres pays rappelez-vous au début
on disait à l'allemagne sont formidables
ils s'en sortent vachement mieux que les
français là aujourd'hui on ne dirait
plus ça du tout plu tout donc voilà donc
il n'a pas trop mal j'ai réduire le coc
vite c'est pas une énorme réussite mais
quand même et je pense vous demandiez de
devenir ce que je pense de cohn bendit
je pense que sur l'europe il a eu un
rôle important même si c'est pas une
grande réussite et enfin quand même que
la politique d'achats de vaccins a été
telle rhdp est que la sortie de la crise
sanitaire on a essayé de se trouver les
solutions comment ça c'est qu'on veut
toujours quand le qu'on le voit toujours
bon écoutez c'est près le même âge que
vous à oui c'est ma génération messieurs
bon écoutez un peu plus vieux que lui
quand même à bondoukou fait je fais
comme ça il est pourtant tu as dit à
peine plus que ce que j'ai vu c'est pas
le temps de laisser la place aux jeunes
ah je vais vous raconter autre chose
alors
pas du tout il ya un an c'est quand même
pas il ya un an une mes amis me dit
écoute michel on est quelques-uns
voudrait réfléchir qu'est ce que c'est
qu'être vieux justin et il est quoi un
cohn-bendit signifie quoi comme travail
il était parlementaire d'accord il a
failli l'a été avant d'être
parlementaire il a était allé à tchô
fait de la politique on détient il a été
étudiant en sociologie 1 mais ensuite il
a toujours c'est un animal politique et
donc il a été travaillé en fait
m'attendais il était adjoint au maire à
francfort sap chez nous ça a c'est un
boulot c'était un boulot parce que c'est
pas facile d'être adjoint au maire à
francfort ont pu à vue s'occupait
beaucoup de des immigrés il ya beaucoup
d'immigrés afin que x et y ait au
parlement européen il a été député très
longtemps il a été toujours très
respectés y compris par des gens qui
étaient pas du tout de son bord du
peuple parce qu'il connaît ils
travaillent et ils connaissaient dossier
y venaient non c'est
de l'aimer ou le détester ça c'est autre
chose mais c'est quelqu'un c'est un
bosseur c'est pas un finir c'est pas
infini est bon alors sur les vieux
maintenant
c'est très intéressant ce qui m'est
arrivé pour plein de raisons donc une de
mes amies qui est une médecin
spécialiste des problèmes d'éthique
clinique
et elle me dit michel jeux j'organiserai
une réunion on est un groupe de 17
hommes de personnes on doit réfléchir à
la place des vieux dans la société on a
besoin d'un sociologue est ce que tu
viendrais à une réunion à la campagne
pendant deux jours je dis oui évidemment
et je me retrouve en dordogne il ya tout
juste un an
à revenir dans un endroit magnifique
d'un cadre super et on se retrouve donc
une vingtaine de personnes pas que des
vieux d'ailleurs et donc cours de tables
à 15 présentent à moi je me présente
comme sociologue mais au bout de cinq
minutes j'ai compris que j'étais pas
associer là que j'étais un vieux bon et
donc c'est très intéressant ni compris
parce que sa vie à des sociologues qui
disent assez du jargon je n'utilise pas
mais c'est le japon ne savent à mes
collègues que les sociologues doit
pratiquer et tenez vous bien la
neutralité axiologique alors il ya en
bon français maintenant de ce dialogue
doit être neutre il doit avoir aucun
lien avec ce qu'il étudie doit en parler
ben non le seul homme n'est jamais
neutre par rapport à ce qu'il étudie
alors colloque c'est mieux non c'est
pareil non c'est pareil l'entrepôt l'eau
qui veut étudier des forêts à base de
lait les populations goûter il fait le
même boulot que moi dans des conditions
très différentes et avec des populations
écoutez si je vous dis je vais faire
comme les bistrots je vais étudier les
problèmes de parenté ça c'est de la
grande entrepôts logis
si je vous dis je veux faire de la
sociologie de la famille
voilà c'est la sociologie part c'est un
peu le même boulot un peu le même on our
view et donc je me retrouve dans ce truc
et qu'est ce qu'on décide on décide de
s'exprimer alors c'était en plus nous
avons commencé c'était avant le fameux
livre les fossoyeurs sur ce qui se
passait dans les ehpad mon avaient été
tous très secoué par cette affaire-là
horrible 1c'est on a été tous très très
secoué donc on était très concernés et
et en plus la majorité des gens qui
étaient là c'était les gens sont un peu
plus jeune que moi soit mon match il ya
des gens qui sont encore très actifs
alors qu'ils sont retraités
pouvoir d'achat
mais pas seulement regardez qui a dance
des conseils municipaux regardez qu'il
ya dans le tissu associés dans tissu
associatif très souvent une association
elle ne tient que parce qu'il ya deux ou
trois bénévoles qui ont 65 70 ans qui
font tourner la boutique bon bon sans
parler que les vieux est souvent les
enfants que c'est donc et donc on a
commencé à réfléchir à qu'est ce que
c'est que cette société dans laquelle
les vieux ne sont pas considérés comme
des sujets comme des acteurs et donc on
a décidé de se mobiliser de cette
manière là et donc du coup ça a eu des
discussions ça a continué après et un
beau jour est venue de l epad mois mais
que j'ai trouvée extraordinaire puisque
le président macron ne tient pas sa
promesse qu'avait été dans au début de
son premier mandat de faire une loi la
loi sur le grand âge il avait promis une
loi sur le grand âge et cette loi aurait
vraisemblablement prévu la création d'un
conseil du grand âge un conseil de la
vieille est un peu l'équivalent de ce
qui existe pour les handicapés et bien
puisqu'il ne fait pas lui de haut en bas
nous on va le faire de base en haut et
on s'est auto constitué en conseil
autoproclamé conseil national
autoproclamé de la vieillesse le cnav
qui était assez assez marrant parce
qu'il ya une institution très officielle
qui s'occupe de l'autre chose qui
s'appelle comme ça aussi et donc on a
deux bases en eau décidé de se réunir
c'est un très gros succès on a eu une
réunion à ariane mnouchkine ou zac qui
fait partie de notre affaire nous a
accueillis dans son théâtre à vincennes
c'était formidable salle était pleine à
craquer et donc et donc vous me demandez
les vieux ben moi les vieux ce qui
m'intéresse c'est de voir jusqu'à quel
point ils peuvent être sujets et acteur
alors sujet c'est à dire ils ont une
subjectivité et acteur il transforme
cette subjectivité en capacité d'action
ben voila moi je trouve ça formidable
alors donc si vous voulez je pense qu'on
peut s'intéresser aux vieux être
concerné par l'âge évidemment et ne pas
pour autant être en dehors de la vie
sociale comment on fait pour combler le
fossé intergénérationnel alors c'est un
problème récent genre d'abord d'abord
discret là c'est un problème récent
pourquoi on a commencé à parler des
générations on en a toujours un peu
parlé mais de fossés de distance ça a
commencé il ya une trentaine d'années
avec des gens qui ont dit j'avais un
collègue dans cette et la spécialité qui
ont dit la génération 68 à occuper tout
le terrain et les nous qui venons après
on nous a rien laissé donc ce sentiment
que la génération des 68 eur à tous a eu
tout pour elle qui continue encore
aujourd'hui j'ai vu ces jours ci que de
closets sort un bouquin contre les
boumeurs et contre les gens de 2 voilà
où cette génération bon mais comment du
rsa de la came pas pris des grosses des
proportions très forte et puis avec le
co vide il ya eu deux choses importantes
qui ont montré que ça se tend entre
générations peut-être pas très gravement
mais ça c'est pas la première chose ça a
été le débat sais pas si vous souvenez
de ça un lit pour deux comme c'est quoi
ce débat c'est ramener à la caricature
vous êtes responsable d'un service
hospitalier
il n'ya plus que un lit avec l'animation
et tout ça pour des malades ducobu il y
en a deux qui arrivent en même temps à
qui vous donnez le lit et bien et la
responsabilité thrill me le tri le tri
masque eu de système de santé étaient
ravagées exactement exactement donc là
vous avez raison la question apparaît
comme éthique parce que la politique a
pas fait son boulot avant mais c'est
comme ça c'est pas que ça a pas fait son
boulot parce qu'ils ont fait ce qui est
ce qu'il ya des montées les services de
soins c'est la politique mais
c'était son boulot mais selon son prisme
du trafic a fait dix ans les choix
politiques vous avez raison les choix
policiers vont tant que ça je vais trop
vite les choix politiques ont abouti à
cette situation assure le risque de
situations comme ça alors discussions
alors moi j'ai participé à des
discussions y compris des règles de
closer jour est la conclusion presque
unanimes c'est toutes choses égales par
ailleurs c'est à dire on imagine que les
problèmes de se ressemblent beaucoup et
bien il faudra donner la priorité aux
jeunes sur le vieux parce que le vieux
il a eu sa vie alors que lille a pas
encore eu donc ouais avec les arts
d'autres critères qui entrent en ligne
de compte évidemment aussi si le jeune
est très malade
et quelle est la réanimation peuple
achevé c'est pas pareil que s'il est en
superbe forme des choses comme ça au
couple tanzi à moi l'euthanasie alors je
me
je ne suis pas dans ce débat donc ma
réponse elle et elle est superficiel
j'ai jamais beaucoup réfléchi mais
spontanément je suis en faveur du fait
que l'on puisse décider soi même de sa
propre mort voilà ça oui et que mais le
problème c'est que si vous me demandez
froid comme ça d'écrire sur un papier
que je veux l'euthanasie c'est mince et
c'est comme ça que je le fait
aujourd'hui comme il dit qui vous
appelle à et qu'il me dise quoi pour
l'euthanasie je ne sais pas ce que je
ferai mais bon tu demanderais mais par
contre par contre en situation si je
suis
bien déglingué bien amoché à moitié
conscient très peu lucide est ce que
j'aurai encore envie de l'euthanasie je
ne sais pas c'est comme les gens qui
vous disent la torture moi je résisterai
ou en terre je ne résisterai pas mais
sait on ne sait pas comme on veut on se
comportera donc entre le choix que je
peux faire aujourd'hui comme citoyen
valides ayant à peu près sa tête malgré
le coc vite que vous avez signalé tout à
l'heure et
le
moment où la question se pose en tout
cas sur le fond en théorie dix ans de
façon un peu abstraite je pense que
c'est aux malades au sujet de décider de
sa propre existence mais
ça c'est moment de ma position un peu
abstraite mais je peux pas aller plus
loin parce que j'ai pas j'ai pas
participé vraiment des discussions
là-dessus donc les problèmes d'élocution
depuis ces deux dernières années ou pas
du tout pourquoi j'en ai beaucoup ce
soir non
[Rires]
non j'ai savez j'en sais que je continue
d'enseigner j'ai eu mon séminaire ce
matin que j'ai parlé pendant deux heures
sans je travaillais pour est la nôtre
choses là qui est passé il ya quatre
jours n'a vu un papier de l'express
concernant le hss qui s'est fait rocher
avec des tags de très mauvais goût genre
un blanc une balle et je passe les
détails les gens iront lire le chapeau
de l'article de l'express concernant le
ss
qu'est ce qui s'est passé qu'est ce qui
se passe qu'est ce que c'est que ça
l'université en plus vous êtes sortis de
l'université et qu'est ce que c'est que
ça alors c'est normal c'est pas normal
c'est légitime soit légitime pourquoi
alors c'est très triste ce qui s'est
passé et il fait j'étais consterné alors
en gros
le hss jusqu'à ces dernières années
était dans paris boulevard raspail dans
un très bel immeuble et il ya trois
quatre ans ils étaient des civils non
pas il a été dessiné mais le fait de la
décision et tv avait été plus auparavant
et le hss se pose maintenant sur un
nouveau campus au nord de paris à
aubervilliers et sur ce nouveau campus
ya d'autres institutions de sciences
sociales c'est un campus de sciences
sociales et le hss on lui à construire
un nouveau bâtiment et 7 dans ce nouveau
bâtiment qu'il y a eu aucune passion des
locaux vandalisme des trucs saccagé du
matériel détruit des tags etc santé de
1000 lignes en apporte énormément
d'argent c'est une catastrophe pour les
équipes de recherche pour les cendres
vous comprenez les gens arrivent là afin
qu'ils se soient farsi le mouvement pour
les retraites le coc vide bon ça fait
quand même beaucoup et au moment de le
déménagement qui est jamais facile il
s'est installé au moment de s'installer
paf sa cage donc ça alors mais c'est une
école qui a été créée par fernand
braudel pratiquement et donc on sait
très bien c'est pour ces gens pas
distinguer le court terme oulala
l'instant présent ouhlala l'actualité et
le long terme et donc si on veut
comprendre ce qui se passe aujourd'hui à
l'école des hautes études il ya le court
terme le vandalisme un climat des black
blood et que sais-je d'un côté il ya le
long terme c'est à dire l'évolution
historique de cette institution est donc
ce que l'article de l'express voit bien
c'est le court terme évidemment je
trouve que ce qu'elle voit moins bien et
qu'elle est moins bien documenté moi
j'aurais eu beaucoup de choses à dire là
dessus parce que j'ai été mêlé à
beaucoup de choses ces dernières années
c'est l'évolution historique de l'école
des hautes études en sciences sociales
et donc là il ya beaucoup de choses à
dire c'est une école qui a été créé
pour sortir en quelque sorte
les sciences sociales de l'école
pratique des hautes études parce que les
sciences sociales étaient devenues trop
grosses pour fayard et vitraux étudiants
qui voulaient en faire oui vous avez
passé le bout de garage sociologue et
coûté à l'époque je peux vous dire que
c'était d'abord il ya palier sociologue
c'est une école où justement les gens
qui venaient là venaient parce que sans
que ce soit une idéologie mais il y
avait des sociologues des anthropologues
et ethnologues des psychologues sociaux
des des historiens évidemment c'est une
école dominée par les historiens il ya
eu des ensuite des économistes enfin
c'est une école pluridisciplinaire et
pour qui il est très important d'être là
alors c'est une école qui avait
d'énormes qualités si on veut bien
admettre que l'élitisme est une qualité
c'est à dire au tout début elle ne
délivrait pas de titres universitaires
moi j'ai pas j'étais étudiant à l'école
des hautes études je suivais les
séminaires d'alain touraine mais mon
doctorat mon premier doctorat de
sociologie de troisième cycle que mon
doctorat d'état je les ai passées
ailleurs qu'à l'école des hautes études
à nanterre et à la sorbonne bon donc
elle ne délivraient pâtit les directeurs
d'études vers les profs étaient payés un
petit peu moins que les profs
d'université
mais carrière était moins bonne en gros
et mais c'était tellement plus
passionnant je pense c'était passionnant
tout cas c'était un endroit où les
étudiants venaient du monde entier parce
que paris était le centre du monde
entier intellectuelle d'empoli sciences
sociales
si je vous dis les grands noms c'est la
bibliothèque de l'honnête chercheurs en
sciences sociales des années 70 si vous
si vous étiez l'historien vous aviez
devant vous vidal naquet françois furet
jacques le goff
etc si vous étiez sociologue xavier
bourdieu raymond aron
touraine et d'autres recettes etc et
donc c'était vraiment un endroit
merveilleux normal plus noble de paris
c'était la cafétéria de l'école des
hautes études en sciences sociales et
puis progressivement au fil des années
l'école des hautes études en sciences
sociales
vraisemblablement parce que on y avait
peur de ne plus avoir d'étudiants et que
les universités étaient en train de
monter en capacité de recherche l'école
des hautes études en sciences sociales a
choisi de s'aligner progressivement sur
le système universitaire classique et ça
a été la fin de cet élitisme que j'ai
tenté mais c'est vrai je suis un peu
nostalgique de cette époque c'était la
fin et l'école des hautes études donc
aujourd'hui n'a plus du tout le
rayonnement qu'elle a pu avoir il ya 40
ou 50 ans il ya 40 ou 50 ans dans le
monde entier on connaissait 20 noms
français aujourd'hui qui connaît un ou
deux directeurs d'études en poche parle
pas des deux ou trois retraités qui
travaillent encore mais qui en connaît
plus que deux ou trois bons plus
personne et donc cette école si vous
voulez s'est transformé en même temps on
a pris conscience de la réalité
étudiants mais mal c'est une école qui
se fichait complètement des étudiants
mais complètement bon et puis les
étudiants en sont venus à juste titre je
pense revendicatif a été bon c'est aussi
une école où la direction n'a pas su
toujours très bien gérer une
contestation qui était qui avaient des
dimensions un peu un mélange de
à certains gauchisme un certain
corporatisme
fayyad et des nouvelles contestations
qui sont apparues et ça a été mal géré
je pense par la direction enfin gérer ça
comme en bas un pas avec un pas contre
eux et elles sans savoir d'un côté leur
donnez pas dans leur attribuer des
locaux et puis d'un autre côté
refusé certaines choses
c'était difficile moi je ne jette pas la
pierre aux
dirigeants mais je pense que l'évolution
générale d'alignement sur le système
universitaire classique et la
transformation du fonctionnement de
cette institution la poussée des
étudiants les rapports avec les crs
aussi école était une puissance qui
n'avait pas vraiment besoin du cnrs au
tout début puis progressivement le cnrs
et a occupé une place très importante
quand il s'adresse les personnels du
cnrs mais ou occuper une place très
importante moi pas l'ange et dirigé un
laboratoire qui était une unité mixte
école des hautes études cnrs et si le
cnrs n'avait pas financé un certain
nombre de postes de chercheurs ou de
personnels administratifs
ce centre ne pouvait plus fonctionner
donc tout ça à transformer cette
institution est je crois la rendue
vulnérable alors ça c'est l'évolution
générale le le côté ultra gauche si vous
voulez de ce qui vient de se passer
ne date pas d'aujourd'hui
aïda il ya quelques années
donc
et c'est la naissance de tout ça qui
aurait pu être mieux mieux compris les
mieux étudiés mais là il aurait fallu
faire des faire des enquêtes nous
attendent un sujet ensemble je suis à
votre disposition mais c'est ce que dit
un truc comme moi j'aurais voulu adapter
évoqué comme qu'on n'aurait pas
extra fléchir je vous pose une question
les black blocks et coin alors les black
blocks et des gens qui sont apparues je
crois pour la première fois visiblement
en italie je crois à peu près en 2000 à
gêne quand il ya eu une réunion jean g7
j'ai ma mémoire est pas extrêmement
précises mais une réunion jean jé set où
enfin une réunion de l'internationale de
chef d'état important et il ya eu des
manifestations pour protester contre
cette réunion et dans ces manifestations
sont apparus propre la première fois des
casseurs qu'on a appelée black block
alors c'est des gens qui
ont une idéologie c'est pas des dépôts
des pétards et complet ce sont des gens
qui ont une vision qui sont très anti
capitalistes qui ont un petit côté
libertaire je pense est qu'ils pensent
qu' il faut profiter de toutes les
situations pour approfondir la crise et
pour témoigner de la haine du
capitalisme donc on les voit dans les
certaines manifestations on les a vus
avec les gilets jaunes on les a vus dans
des cortèges syndicaux ou leur 1er mai
août et donc ce sont des gens et qui qui
sont très modernes dans leur conception
de l'action au sens où ils savent se
rassembler et se séparer se retrouver se
disperser
et pratiqua vieux la violence en
principe contre des cibles qui pourrait
incarner le capitalisme est en réalité
pas seulement contre l'état aussi donc
contre la police ou les forces de
l'ordre voilà donc c'est un mouvement
alors si vous voulez avoir une idée de
leur façon de parler il ya un site qui
sa peau un blog je suis pas expert lundi
ou lundi quelque chose elles n'ont lundi
dedans et sur ce site outre les articles
très élaboré très intéressant vous voyez
comment cette mouvance réfléchi lundi
matin voilà comme peut-être ben voila
vous voyez comment cette mouvance
réfléchissant je n'ai pas été voir mais
oui comment cette mouvance réfléchit
donc c'est c'est pas du tout la violence
et sur la violence y est ce que vous
pensez que la violence par exemple des
black blocs qui descendent tout un
boulevard et les banques les assurances
les mcdonald's ou marteau ainsi de suite
est-ce que vous pensez que ça va aller
plus loin
alors ça ne peut exister que lorsqu'il
ya des manifestations qui parle d'autre
chose que de la violence dans son besoin
d'un cortège syndical ou d'un cortège de
gilet jaune ils ont besoin d'autre chose
est ce que ça peut aller plus loin mais
ça dépend de la force des mouvements qui
se mobilise de manière non violente
dans le temps il ya longtemps qu'il ya
eu dès que deux cortèges qui se
terminait mal des casseurs comme on
disait enfin première ligne quand même
mais comment ils sont premiers mais la
voilà pourquoi mais tout simplement
parce que le syndicalisme a perdu sa
capacité à organiser les services
d'ordre dans le temps les gros bras de
la cgt
c'était du sérieux
aujourd'hui encore des gros bras de la
cgt ou force ouvrière bien sûr mais il y
en a moins il ya bonnes capacités et
donc quand un mouvement s'affaiblit sa
première deuxièmement deuxièmement il
faut pas croire que c'est un monde qui
idéologiquement et totalement coupés du
reste des acteurs de ces manifestations
ils interviennent quand il ya eu les
black blocks yahoo lui aussi des gilets
jaunes qui sont qui n'était pas black
block qui ont été violents les uns parce
que à chaud comment vous est venue à une
manifestation vous êtes un brave type
vous êtes venus manifester dire ce que
vous pensiez et puis paf une grenade
tombe devant vous vous piquent les yeux
blesse quelqu'un à côté nous arrache la
jour faire vous met dans la rage ça vous
met en rage c'est la technique de
contre-révolution ah bah ça fait partie
des choses je tiens dans la tête en
visite à l'egypte quand même pas chez
nous va pas pouvoir y ait eu des petites
des petits dérapages
shot exactement qu'est ce que c'est que
ces voix là bas se situe acceptable
évidemment il est de 3 à faire et c'est
inacceptable parce que de 3,1 wafa dijon
va diriger des des excès policiers comme
on dit mais là je hais je vais pas les
minimiser du tout bon oeil cette affaire
vous souvenez ils sont rentrés
maintenant un magasin où il y avait
quelqu'un qu'ils ont tabassé devant
s'étaient dit oui enfin c'est les forces
de l'ordre mais si vous voulez ce que je
voulais dire c'est que 1 vous avez des
gilet jaune qui sont venus violents à
chaud en situation parce que en
situation parfois on s'énerve ça s'est
terminé d'ailleurs que mots
le tabassage de gilet jaune dans les
magasins ils ont été condamnés pas
condamné écoutez je sais pas j'ai pas
suivi les fins de d'actions en justice
moi la sphère que j'avais en tête
c'était c'était surtout le type qui
était je crois de couleur en plus et qui
était devant son magasin avec les
policiers l'ont tabassé à mort où vous
faites très très violemment et à
quelqu'un qui filmait donc ça c'est ça
qui avait fait du bruit dans l'est mais
il ya eu plein de choses comme ça il ya
quand même
il ya quand même eu des violences ce
lourd de les condamner je crois parler
des instances européennes aux femmes
mais ce que je vais dire preuve d'une
fébrilité de l'état
je vais vous le dire autrement je pense
qu'il ya de la violence des deux côtés
et qui est de la fébrilité des deux
côtés quand vous avez un mouvement
social fort un syndicat puissant des
gilets jaunes qui y sont capables
d'imposer les négociations et c'est pas
du tout la même chose que quand le du
côté de ce côté là que quand le
mouvement est faible mais quand il est
faible il laisse plus de place à la
violence celle des autres est la sienne
propre et saine je voulais vous dire il
ya des gens qui comprennent cette
violence au sein même des syndicats au
sein même des manifestants gilet jaune
et tout ça il ya des gens qui quittent
autrement dit c'est pas que les black
blocks et sa diffuse un petit peu et
d'un autre côté vous avez en face parce
que la situation appelle du point de vue
du gouvernement répression vous avez
aussi des forces de police qui sont ou
d'europe 1 les forces de l'ordre comme
on dit qu'ils sont allés trop fort ça
c'est clair aussi donc c'est les deux
mais attendez ils sont allés trop fort
ba bê beatty parce qu'on les a laissés
faire
écoutez bien entendu bien entendu il ya
des là on ne peut vous laisse il ya des
excès policiers c'est comme la russie de
pousser comme poutine et le et ce type
qui te pas de packs parallèle annoncé
c'est pour dire le responsable c'est le
pouvoir dans ces cas le selor bleus
pouvoir politique qui est détenteur des
décisions de maintien de l'ordre la fa
sont elles seront elles sont effectuées
donc là dessus je autrement dit je pense
pas du tout qu'on dise aléas les
policiers de tirer d'une certaine façon
avec leurs engins lourds mais je pense
que la façon dont on organise la l'ordre
as
tout ça me suis pas un expert donc je ne
peux pas m'aventurer ce terrain mais je
suis certain qu'il ya de l'excès ça oui
donc l'ex r&d d'excès et donc voilà et
donc mais des deux côtés et le problème
c'est que vous avez beaucoup de gens qui
passent leur samedi où leur dimanche à
regarder les télévisions ligne et au
lieu de comprendre qu'il ya un mouvement
qui met en avant des revendications de
tels types ou de tahiti
entre les retraites ou pour des
meilleurs revenus ou etc il n'y a plus
qu'une chose la violence policière et la
violence des manifestants et donc c'est
pour ça que la démocratie est abîmée
dans ces situations là parce que au lieu
que l'on parle des problèmes qui font
que des conflits d'intérêts et les
oppositions des contradictions il n'y a
plus que le choc des deux violeurs
et évidemment les médias s'en repaissent
un hockey ou flatter les pythies qui
voit des bancs et donc oui mais il m'est
arrivé de le zapper des journées
entières des amis entier et à chaque
fois de tomber sur toutes ses chaînes où
il y avait que
des idées des types qui cassait qui
incendient et caetera et puis les
policiers qui répondait et vous ne savez
même plus vous êtes vous n'avez même
plus est en jeu wii donc ça c'est très
malsain pour la démocratie très très mal
et donc oui mais c'est des deux côtés et
l'arrière une autre contre une autre
conséquence de tout ça non on n'a pas
encore parlé moi j'appartiens à la
génération qui a vu la violence de venir
il légitime la violence d'en bas je
prépare de l'alliance police bon moi
j'ai été élevé si je peux dire avec jean
paul sartre ou même michel foucault donc
des gens qui avaient qu'ils pouvaient
trouver certaine violence légitime alors
ça c'est allé très loin il ya une
préface très célèbre un livre de
françois nom où ils en appellent à la
violence du colonisé de façon vraiment
extrêmes donc donc la violence était
légitime et puis à partir des années 70
80 la violence est devenue illégitime
presque tabou
l'idée de révolution n'en voulait plus
c'est ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure
parce que c'était devenu un truc
d'arabes alors beaucoup de musulmans
s'étaient l'iran et l'algérie donc quand
même donc on voulait plus d'eux l'idée
de révolution et le terrorisme on n'en
voulait pas surtout quand il est devenu
musulman islamiste et tout ça parce que
tu en reste et l'extrême gauche peut y
avoir des courants de compréhension
comprenez mais là non puis on peut les
instrumentaliser plus facile et en plus
bien sûr bien sûr mais ça serait
toujours l'instrumentalisation des
mouvements d'extrême gauche boriau 9 non
vous avez l'extrême gauche jaune c'est
plus grand chose c'est les trotskistes
fait deux-trois organisation trotskyste
mais y'a pus d'extrême gauche qui a eu
dans les années 70 les antifas vous en
pensez quoi
ça ne m'intéresse pas beaucoup moi ce
que j'en pense quoi parce que c'est pas
comme ça qu'on règle c'est si vous
voulez c'est céline c'est un activisme
qui ne règle pas les problèmes sur le
fond voilà ce que je pense donc bon
c'est très bien d'être anti fascistes ou
deux bons mais ça ne règle rien et n'ont
jamais rien réglé à ce genre de l'acteur
garrett depuis longtemps donc je suis
plus pourquoi je vous disais oui la
violence c'était la légitimité de la
violence c'est à dire qu'elle est elle a
été tabou et elle revient n'est qu'à
partir des gilets jaunes elle a retrouvé
une certaine légitimité la violence dans
bach la colère la rage la retrouve une
certaine légitimité et ça c'est très
préoccupant
est-ce que vous avez trois bouquins un
conseiller à notre communauté des
luthiers qui ont marqué votre vie vous
parler de ce que j'ai écrit ou des
livres d'autres
quand même pas quand même pas non parce
que si vous m'aviez posé la question
mais des bouquins vous aurais dit les
miens c'est ce que je vais faire qui
m'intéresse le plus mais bouquin il va
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure c'est
alors monsieur macron heureux d'accord
dont trois livres alors des livres qui
faisont marquis quand j'étais dans ma
vie dans mon existence à leur écoute et
je vais vous dire un ça va vous sembler
d'une platitude elle est désespérée les
misérables
2 alors le livre que j'ai adoré le plus
haut que j'ai lu le comte de monte
cristo alors là bon et 3 pourquoi
écouter pour que je ne sais pas mais
style c
c'est une histoire extraordinaire c'est
je pense que si je le redis aujourd'hui
sur un très léger j'étais très déçu par
le film car n'a été tirée avec
depardieu et mon orthèse pour moi c'est
bon mais assez un truc qui m'a fait
rêver qui m'a fait voyager dans des
demandeurs des trucs qu'ils imaginaient
dont j'ai adoré le comte de monte cristo
et alors c'est pas un bouquin c'est une
oeuvre et je peux aller jusqu'à 4 il ya
deux heures mais j'aime rennes ce soir 1
c'est celle du cadeau il ya deux oeuvres
que j'ai adoré quand c'était quand je
lisais beaucoup parce que maintenant
vous savez un chercheur
non non parce que j'écris quand on écrit
beaucoup on lis pas beaucoup fait comme
ça c'est comme ça tous les gens qui
écrivent vous le diront donc mais
l'époque où je lisais beaucoup 3 et 4
c'est j'ai lu toute l'oeuvre de jules
verne quand j'avais entre 15 et 20 ans
et j'ai adoré un peu après balzac j'ai
lu à peu près tout balzac d'envoyer je
vous ai pas dit à la recherche du temps
perdu ou ou des choses comme ça voilà
moi mes livres c'est
c'est ça vous avez lu le sémillant des
adouls j'ai lu le seigneur des anneaux
ça va pas spécialement touchée non non
non pas spécialement non alors si on
entendait de la terre un peu qui se
rapproche un peu de ça sent en solitude
ça c'est un gars j'ai adoré la
littérature latino américaine est-ce que
vous avez un coup ci pour les jeunes
générations
bon je me permettrai pas de donner un
conseil mais je dirais la chose suivante
pas pour tout le monde
ne croyez pas à tous ceux qui vous
disent que l'avenir est à tel type de
métier ou tel type de métier fait des
choses qui vous plaît ça je le dis à mes
étudiants en particulier en sociologie
choisissez le sujet de thèse qu'il vous
plaît par celui qui plaît un professeur
avec qui vous parle donc
construisez-vous en
décidant qu'il ya des choses plus
importantes que d'autres excès ces
choses plus importantes que vous voulez
faire voilà c'est ça ma vision c'est pas
à me contacter je vais je vais rajouter
juste une petite minute
c'est très intéressant la petite phrase
que vous avez sorti c'est choisir un
sujet pour faire plaisir aux profs oui
bien sûr c'est fini le temps de la lèche
c'est ça alors ça continue c'est pas de
la lèze coutume c'est pas de la lèche et
une relation d'autorité moi j'avais des
amis historiens alors c'était horrible
faire un masque un une maîtrise en
histoire le prof vous disais voilà moi
je suis je prends un exemple fictif du
mois je suis spécialiste du prix du blé
au 19e siècle j'ai déjà étudié entre
1810 et du cif 1830 dans quelle partie
de la france et entre 1850 et 1880
dentelle aux deux parties alors prenez
quelque chose qui sera une des deux
périodes d'une des plates que j'ai pas
étudié et des régions je suis que j'ai
pas étudié bombe à l'étudiant les
fascine et il est dans une relation
d'autorité n'a pas le choix bon ben ça
c'est quand même moins le cas mais mais
quand même quand on parfois on vient on
à un sujet mais parfois on a envie de
faire une recherche n'a pas d'idées eh
bien il faut avoir des il faudra des
désirs et et construisez vos désirs et
ensuite
ne croyait pas à ce qui est allé voir
trop tracé à l'avance parce que dans
cinq ans dans dix ans vous ne savez pas
du tout vous en serez mais au moins vous
serez construire en faisant des choses
que vous aviez envie de faire voilà moi
le conseil que je donne qui est prévu un
conseil d'être égoïste replier sur
soi-même mais se construire soi même
voix se construire
michel wieviorka merci
merci
[Musique]
or